[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen check check
excellent excellent excellent Dustin my
man what are you what are you doing dude
Dustin's
starting us up with a super chat before
we even got started man
Dustin with a two dollar Super Chat
don't mind this super chat it's a test
oh my goodness Dustin thank you so much
my friend thank you so much
people of the internet
ladies and gentlemen hello and welcome
to Retro
you're a wizard Harry you're a wizard
welcome to Retro records are live guys
I'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell we post videos every
week here on Hogwarts Legacy we do a
weekly live stream as well on Hogwarts
Legacy
and the weekly live stream is Tuesday
evenings
and we're keeping it on Tuesday evenings
oh man thank you guys so much for being
here and hanging out hold on let me uh
I'm gonna switch this music here we need
some let's go to like Lo-Fi yeah let's
go to Lo-Fi
and then I'm gonna turn it down just a
bit just a bit guys two weeks man two
weeks can you believe this
can you believe this
January 24th my friends
January 24th how are you yo what's up
nearly hell is Nick
oh my gosh
I mean just like reflecting back on the
journey this has been welcome to Griffin
I mean we literally have
one more regular Tuesday stream now we
are for those of you anybody who's new
here we are planning to do a live stream
right here the Monday evening before the
game goes live which by the way guys
the merch so if you didn't see the merch
that popped up on Amazon
is official Chandler was able to confirm
that for us I tweeted it out
and it's super soft man it's really soft
I got one of these
so it says uh like live the unwritten at
the bottom then it's got what looks like
the same ancient magic wand that's on
the collector's edition and then at the
top you've got the Hogwarts Legacy here
it came really quick too really quick
and then I also got just one of the
plain t-shirts with the black on it the
T-shirt actually came first
um but yeah I mean it is it is official
officially licensed merch if you're
interested I put an affiliate link down
in the description of this if you guys
want to purchase one you know check it
out it helps helps the channel at no
extra cost to you
um so I don't know what it's like for
other so that's in the US I've seen some
other people oh my gosh dude how many of
you welcome how many
okay let me catch up here oh my gosh
hold on okay so Dustin got us started
then we had CJ and Lucas and Fallen as
new subscribers welcome guys thank you
all for being here uh then we had Elwyn
gifting five tier one memberships we got
Jason we got Susie Q we got Randall
Denson we got Sharon and we got Nikki
all getting a gifted membership
to all my friends who just were gifted
welcome to house rack and tour
you are now officially a member by the
power of Thor's hammer you were
officially remember I'm gonna keep this
right here for a second because I'm
hearing a lot of notifications here I
think we might need it for a bit
I think we might need it for a bit wait
Dustin what
what
okay hold on volte with the 499 Super
Chat retro got a bone to pick with you
how you doing brother I'm doing well
volte do it well my friend
volte not in the military as we learned
last last week
volte said he was deployed I thought
that many was in the military
I'm sorry okay I'm sorry volte thank you
very stupid Chad and your continued
support of the stream Elwyn same to you
as well guys if you got one of these
gifted memberships make sure you think
your gift or uh you get access to all
the little fun Emoji you can use those
you can spam them we got some fun ones I
just added a new one by the way we got
the little hype
so the hype one is an old school emote
from back when I started streaming on
Twitch I asked Nico who has been
following the stream since then I said
which one's your favorite of the old
school ones he picked hype so hype's
only brought over we're very close to
unlocking another one in fact how are
you I'm pretty sure we just did because
right after volte Dustin with the 20.
the 20 gifted memberships house rack and
tour continuing to grow by Massive
numbers welcome guys you were officially
part of house wreck and tour now thank
you all for being here and Dustin
my friend
thank you so much dude Dustin guy is
always just showing ridiculous
ridiculous amounts of support
well so guys it's if you're normally
used to Twitch it works a little bit
different on YouTube YouTube memberships
those are kind of like the paid one
whereas the subscription is free over
here
so you can subscribe for free if you
join that is the paid membership what do
you get with that you get access to the
emotes you get a special role in Discord
you get discounts on merch like this
retro hat right here
but mostly it's just a way to support
creators you know
um and Dustin dropping 20 gifteds my
goodness man
my goodness thank you so much Dustin
very much appreciated and then let's see
we had after that oh yeah then it's
gonna go through the 20.
then it's gonna go go through the 20.
Nico gifting five as well
speaking of Nico we were just talking
about him the real life Chief warlock
Nico thank you for the gifteds and
welcome to those members of house
raconteur
some new members some old members
but everybody is welcome here you get a
special role in the Discord now you get
access to the emote so see a lot of
people spamming the hype let me tell you
the hype I don't know I don't know man
like did you guys do you guys feel
something feel something this past week
they dropped that trailer
just like
the Hogwarts Express hype train you know
here's here's how we we started out so
the game was rumored before it was it
was just a rumor you know so it's like
oh wow do we we need to like do we need
to get this train revved up in the
station I mean do we need to prepare
and then then it became official and
then it's like oh okay here we go here
we go we're boarding man we're boarding
we're on the hype train
and then they're like oh uh it's delayed
oh
so the train I mean the train slowed
down it's it slowed down a lot you guys
slowed down a lot
we had a year without any information
whatsoever
and then the state of play
the state of play the PlayStation event
the state of play the hype train just
like launched right the Hogwarts Legacy
wait hold on I'm gonna call it the
Hogwarts Express hype train
just launched right you just launched
and then I feel like ever since
I mean really
like kind of the end of 2022
into the beginning of 2023 it's been
amazing it's been crazy
yeah buckle up buckle up make sure make
sure you got a good comfortable seat
make sure you have a good
comfortable seat on the Hogwarts Express
hype train and make sure you buckle your
seatbelt buckle your seat belts
that's what I'll say guys that's what
I'll say Buckle them up so we got Nico
with the five gifteds uh congrats to
let's see looks like Dylan Danielle FX
Kaylee bunny got one of those then we
had the or division fellow Hogwarts
Legacy Creator or division what is up my
friend with the Super Chat hello retro
have a great stream a thank you or
division
thank you so much
very much appreciate your your continued
support or Division and then we had
volte wait is that another that's
another Super Chat from our boy boltsy
two weeks couldn't go any slower
well
it's going pretty quick for me
for you guys soon too I do I do volte
thank you so much for the Super Chat and
the continued support Rhett Mitchell
obscurious conspiracy theorist I don't
know if that was a gift or not but
either way Rhett welcomed housewrecking
tour my friend welcome to house wrecking
tour thank you for being here hanging
out and then Dust wait was that another
Dustin what is happening I'm already
five minutes behind Dustin with another
10 gifted that's that's 30 gifteds from
Dustin
Dustin slow down my friend slow down we
have just the the numbers of house
wrecking tour are exploding they're
exploding right now Dustin thank you so
much dude and to all of those who just
got gifted guys make sure you think your
gifter they do have to actually put down
real money for that this is not just a
fun little spam Emoji thing
oh my goodness though yeah so you get a
special role in the Discord you get
access to all those emoji
discounts on merch uh what else what
else what else priority reply to
comments you get a special little tab in
the community area that
um sometimes I'll make polls that only
you guys can see
speaking of polls though there is a poll
right now on this live stream that you
guys can vote in so we got the final
ASMR as well we got a lot to talk about
lot to talk about
new ASMR and then also the new cinematic
trailer so which ASMR is your guy's
favorite looks like right now
we already we have almost 400 votes and
winter is dominating I don't know if
that's a little recency bias probably is
a little bit but honestly winter was my
favorite too which I always knew it
would be even before
I mean when they did the Showcase with
Benjamin snow and I saw the snow for the
first time oh yeah I just I've always
had the same with snow in games I love
snowing games
at one of my favorite levels in uh
Metroid Prime which is one of my
favorite games of all time is the
finrana drifts level in the snow same
for The Last of Us I have a
oh you guys I can't get my camera to
turn this way so you guys can see it but
I have a print on my wall here really
nice I'm talking like this was like my
single Christmas gift for my wife one
year uh a print
from The Last of Us that the scene is
the winter scene so I've always loved
winter scenes and games we're gonna
watch it here in a second I knew I would
probably love that one the best and then
we had let's see I'm like I can't even
tell who's A Gifted member now and who
is a who's just renewing their own
membership but William thank you for the
three months Travis Hammer thank you for
the four months ler moyo Henry
welcome to house strike and tour Mary
welcome to house tracking tour Nick Shaw
welcome to house Dragon tour Luis
Severino
how are you another house record to
remember and then we had Tom subscribe
to the channel Tom thank you my friend
and then a five dollar Super Chat for
Maya who have they mentioned anything
about the PC version having dlss options
I want to say Nico told me
I feel like that was in one of the
wizard big FAQs
so the um
the portkey games website and also the
WB Games Twitter account they've been
answering a lot of stuff so I'm way
behind on chat but Nico if you hear me
saying this if that was if you do
remember that
just let uh ma at Maya Who there in the
chat no but I'm pretty sure
actually wait dlss see I'm not like I
know Nico and Elwyn they're they're the
two I know for sure they're both mostly
PC Gamers and they're both moderators
here they may know better than I would
on that one I don't recall seeing that
specifically but I know there was a lot
of PC stuff announced Jesse with another
Super Chat Jesse two more weeks right I
ca I really I can't believe it it's been
such a
such a long but fun Journey
and it's not over it's not over I'm not
gonna go away the Channel's not gonna
leave
the channel is not gonna leave
we're just gonna be doing a lot of other
things a lot of other things but the
weekly live streams man I'm gonna keep
doing these Tuesday nights as long as
you guys keep showing up for them
as long as we have people who keep
showing up for them and then volte are
you kidding me volte with
back to back super chats Vol 2 with 4.99
I did feel that hype and you mister was
quite about it
did feel that hype and mystery request
oh I got you I got you mate you were oh
we'll just send another Super Chat to
clarify the first Super Chat
ulti my friend thank you for your
support I meant you were quiet this week
was I quiet this week I don't feel like
I was quiet this week
I try not to overload people on Twitter
and social media
some dude I have this like
I delete more tweets than I post let me
tell you it's like I'll start typing
something like yeah nobody cares
nobody's gonna care about that I just
deleting it I'm deleting it
I I honestly like I need to do better
like James does such a good job of uh
he's like constantly keeping the
community aware updated on what he's
doing
he's got the new P all the pictures of
the new pc I'm like oh darn it dude
Riley Beatty or Beady with a super chat
as well how long until NDA for trip
terminates tell us
okay so you know in the World of Harry
Potter
you know what actually I know what we're
gonna do we should probably we should
probably get this out of the way now we
should probably get this out of the way
now I don't want you guys to waste your
money
I don't want you guys wasting your money
let me be up front and be totally honest
with you guys tonight our topics of
conversation
our main ones anyway we always go off
the rails a little bit but our main
topic of conversation are going to be
the new cinematic trailer and they're
going to be the winter ASMR those are
two big top oh and the two uh tweets
from Hogwarts Legacy or maybe three that
we haven't talked about since last week
those are the main topics
now I'd like to I'd like to share a
little lesson with you guys we're going
to do a little Harry Potter lore lesson
right here
Okay so
hold on this music's just not it's not
good for this lesson we need something a
little uh
let's see
maybe I don't know try it out a new
music service because Spotify I kept
getting hit with copyrighted music
this is what this was called pretzel
rocks I just need to figure out how to
uh
I need to figure out how to favorite
some more things so it's not just
playing a bunch of random stuff
okay that one's good that one's good
[Music]
all right so here here's the lesson that
we're gonna do a little Harry Potter
lore lesson
you guys remember
the thing called the unbreakable vow
feel like that
that concept might be
important to review right now
so the unbreakable vow ladies and
gentlemen is a spell where a witch or
wizard
makes an oath to another
if the terms of the oath are broken the
person who breaks it will die
will die all right a binding magical
contract
just think about
think about Barney Crouch and uh Goblet
of Fire
it's a dude it's a binding magical
contract Mr Potter must compete
which watch in that bag I need to read
that book again because I'm like hold on
couldn't Harry have just literally like
showed up to each task
and then like not even try to do it he's
just like okay we're gonna protect him
he's just gonna sit out
couldn't they couldn't they have done it
like that
I don't know but yeah I just thought
that might be a good you know might be a
good lore thing for us to review tonight
the unbreakable vow you guys you guys
remember how serious the unbreakable Val
is
so we want to be more you remember how
Snape
you know Snape not a guy that you really
want to emulate in a lot of ways
but in terms of that unbreakable Val man
he was Rock Solid
Hagrid on the other hand
I should not have said that you know you
know remember that whole little
that whole bit in the movies I should
not have said that so tonight guys we
gotta be more like Snape
we're in this we're gonna be more like
Snape than Hagrid okay
we don't want any I should not have said
that all right all right there we go
there we go okay so let's see oh my gosh
I'm so far behind
let's see let's see all right that was
Riley and then we had add Hayne with the
membership thank you very much welcome
to house tracking tour Raymond call
Tyrell in the house gifting the five
tier one memberships
welcome to house track and tour my
friends welcome to house recorder dude I
haven't even gotten to the to the
welcomes
I haven't even got to the welcomes
Marianne Kelvin football David was here
all got one of those memberships right
there Trevin Harris got one of the
memberships
then we have volte with another Super
Chat
alrighty guys let's go back to work love
you bro hey volte thank you for all your
support as always my friend good luck
with your
with your very rigorous
late night hours that you have to pull
and then we had uh let's see Trevin so
Jason and Kurt new subscribers welcome
guys Devin bird what's up Devin with the
499 Super Chat shout out to Dustin I
know we all remember that house fire he
saved
seven nuns and 14 puppies at St Bart's
home for a little
sad puppies and nuns
that one went over my head but I it
wouldn't don't feel bad Devin it's not
the first time it's not the first time
that a Super Chat and or a communist
went over my head so if I should have
gotten that one don't feel bad don't
feel bad
oh my goodness we had fetch Quest gaming
gifting
let's hear one membership fetch Quest
thank you for the gift and it looks like
voldegaard got that gifted membership
right there
congrats voldegaard welcome to house
wrecking tour
I'm gonna get tired of lifting this
Hammer guys
you're officially a member of house
wrecking tour
all right enjoy the emotes enjoy the
discount merch enjoy the
Discord roll
Noob with the Super Chat as well what is
up Noob it's Noob I've seen you
sparingly the past few weeks but it's
good to see my friend as you can see I'm
not dead
just remember to stay high I shouldn't
be yelling so much tonight just stay
hydrated I shouldn't be yelling because
we've got kind of a scratchy throat so
my wife made me this tea beforehand so
that's our hydration tonight
my gosh my son just
his his bedroom is right above me
just heard a very loud boom
I think my wife heard him too though
you're a wizard Harry you're a wizard
Harry
all right Noob thank you so much I'm
glad I'm glad you're still alive and
well noob
good to see you my friend Dustin with
another five Dustin
oh my gosh Dustin
with another five dollar Super Chat
guys
whenever people donate this much I feel
I feel compelled to say I appreciate it
so much I really do but make sure
be responsible
Tate make sure you're taking care of
yourself first okay make sure you guys
are good all right Dustin will remember
you well retro you can break it and
we'll give you a step
so if I just like I vanished off the
internet
I just vanish
you guys never hear from me again well
that I mean that doesn't make me feel
good would you you all would make a
house wreck into her statue my honor I
do appreciate that I do appreciate it
I do appreciate it and then uh Andre
stoika or Andre subscribe to the channel
thank you very much and then Jeremiah
Robinson with a super chat Veritas Serum
is in your future retro oh my gosh dude
imagine my wife gave me Veritas serum if
that's what this actually was right here
imagine dude imagine
Dr Stranger what is up Doctor Strange I
think Doctor Strange I believe is a
moderator for
Benjamin snow
I believe I'm right in that
believe I'm right on that you should
call this Wizarding Tuesday I mean we
can't steal James's Thunder you know
which technically like
I think how it went is James kind of
took it from Wizarding World and then he
he like he had it for a while and now
Wizarding World is trying to take it
back I don't know if you guys saw the
other day they were like Wizarding
Wednesday
James said you got to be kidding me what
no we would need like try wizard Tuesday
or something
try wizard Tuesday would work
what else what else in the Harry Potter
world starts with a t
IE wizard Tuesday
trelawny Tuesday
Riley with another Super Chat just
messing with you yeah right
yeah yeah unbreakable vowel levels
unbreakable Val
ues thank you so much for being here and
thank you for the crazy amount of love
and support to start the stream as we do
every week though we're gonna shout out
everyone who's here hanging out tonight
so let me look at the list here of
participants
and see who we got in the chat tonight
we got three Hillary brothers that's a
house racking to remember
here they come again oh three Hillary
house record tour Adam AKA profit we got
ether in the house eradash Austin Scott
Bella DD both ether and Bella house
record members Benjamin snow
what is up Benjamin snow in the house
Brittany L is here as well CR cam Dawson
then we got Kathy choss you see Cindy w
three members of house wrecking tour
there cosmetic short hair cygnus
jabberwock Channel member de Franz then
we got David oh my goodness this might
be the longest line of channel members
I've ever seen all right here we go you
guys ready for this
we got David was here we got devil we
got devil Blom we got Devin bird we got
Doctor Strange all the D's Dr sherbet
Draco Draven Dustin elwin and fetch
Quest gaming my goodness ladies and
gentlemen all channel members right
there we got Hall Berry in the house
Hannah Channel member we got hog
UE Hogwarts lunatic I like that Huffy
Yuppie we got Jace Snyder uh jamming21
Jason Hodges that's a channel member
right there Jax fenrir oh dude we got a
bunch of J's too here we go here we go
channel members in the Jays Jay Felix
Jenna Lee Turner Jenny uh Jeremiah
Robinson Jesse Johnny the hustle pop
Russell
I just love saying that name dude if you
can't tell every time I see your name
pop up I love saying Johnny the hustle
pup wait hold on hold on it's like um
ladies and gentlemen welcome Johnny the
hustle puff Russell
The Crowd Goes Wild
or Johnny here he comes
now everybody's like gonna be like come
on you you didn't give me that much
fanfare
sorry I just love saying the name dude
Jordan Crawford another Channel member
uh Jordan Cameron Josh rdz K1 D3 Lauren
D Channel member Levi Nicholson L hooves
member of House raconteur a little paveo
lowercase Logan in the house I saw him
dude hold on didn't lowercase Logan
renew a membership or something
dude I slogan I saw it in the chat I'm
so sorry and for some reason it didn't
pop up in my little uh
activity feed here
I don't know if that's a YouTube thing
or what like it doesn't show those
correctly but now as soon as I saw your
name I remembered it so I missed your
message off to scroll back up see if I
can find it lurk in the shadows is here
Marianne and marvolo Ravenclaw House
tracking tour members Matt Ajo Michael P
then we got Milan in the house we got
Noob nagura Ravenclaw and Nathan Fox
Nico Neil Harrison
big list of channel members right there
nvkl we got Pete Channel member pink
Ravenclaw what's up pink Ravenclaw
welcome thank you for being here
Professor Baxter in the house R Lee here
in the house radio Morales Ravenclaw
Tyrell Rhett Mitchell obscurious
conspiracy theorist might be the longest
name I've ever seen on YouTube
house tracking to remember all three of
those right there
I held up four I meant three Riley
Anthony Riley Beady or Beatty Rogue Crow
Ruby Rose then we got Ryan Shadow guided
Sharon Cruz shax that was right into our
members right there let's go guys stay
licks Parker steffay what's up Stephie
and then tabby cat gaming both house
wrecking tour members right there uh tyr
or tear maybe Terence D Clark t g d j f
b d welcome to the stream TJ Houston
member of House wrecking tour tone 83
trainer Z unyielding Warrior voldegard
and volte back-to-back channel members
right there Will's word
and z z shirer member of House wreck and
tour guys if I missed you in my
apologies
um it updates in real time
so as I scroll through alphabetically if
you came in after I
got to your letter in the alphabet and
then that's why we missed it
oh ladies and gentlemen we have a packed
house tonight packed house tonight guys
make sure to hit that like button we're
already well over 100 likes we're
quickly on our way to 200 likes
for those of you who are new here and
don't understand the shenanigans we get
into when we hit 100 likes which we've
already done so we're gonna do a random
bit of Harry Potter quote trivia we'll
do that before we wrap up the stream
today and then when we hit 200 we'll
also add on an additional
foreign
I have to do a Harry Potter
impersonation and the Chad gets to pick
the chat gets to pick
we've done a couple of the popular ones
already
we'll see what it is tonight
what was it was Bellatrix wasn't last
week was it
I don't know they all run together in my
head now I never remember
I never remember
all right so
okay wait hold on let's let's catch up
on these last Super chats
we had another one from volte Dobby must
not tell lies Dobby is a free elf wait
was that a trick to try to get me to do
an impersonation it almost worked it
almost worked
thank you so much volte dust with
another sewage tipping Tuesday
oh my goodness dude
thank you guys for this war volte with
another
I'm not just making this up volte with
another Super Chat also wanted to say I
do not work for Avalanche so please stop
dming me about this
wait what are people legit dming you
guys I haven't dm'd you at all so it's
not like wait what guys guys don't don't
don't harass volte oh don't have don't
harass really anybody in the Stream
yeah volte last week said they were well
I shouldn't even say it now but yeah so
there you go
and then Dr shirt with a super chat when
you start saving creatures what animal
you saving I'm gonna find a niffler
hashtag house retro
I mean I'm gonna try to save everything
I can right here's what I need to know
guys
we got to do something fun with the
naming
how are we gonna decide
how are we going to decide what
I mean I could do like I could do
channel members
but there's too many honestly there's
too many there's too many of you I don't
know how many creatures are in the game
but I think there's too many channel
members for us to uh be able to have one
for everybody
Alicia has already claimed the mooncalf
guys
so I feel like that one is kind of
locked in
oh my gosh this music is just not doing
it for me right now EDM
let's see is it gonna be two
I don't want to like too crazy you know
I want to feel like we need to just get
up and start dancing
hold on
um let's let's go back to chill
James is the one who told me about this
uh I'm gonna have to ask him a little
bit more about how to uh
because it's just like playing random
right now
I think to get a lot of the cool
features in this you have to upgrade to
the paid version
but at least we don't get copyright
claims for it
but volte or I'm sorry Dr sherbet thank
you so much for the Super Chat there
and then Riley have I chose a name from
a character oh yeah we'll go we'll go
like retro for the first name rack into
her last name
yeah that's what we'll go with
go ninja go with a super chat as well
just got home so I don't know who gifted
me another month as a membe but thank
you and yes
Tipsy Tuesday with the new PS5 TV TV
sound bar and pizza wait hold up you got
a new PS5 TV and sound bar
just in time for Hogwarts let's go dude
let's go
that is the one sad thing I mean I'm
definitely gonna be streaming the game
that's the one thing that I'm sad about
is that I won't get to play it on my
um my big OLED TV
which I have a decent monitor too so I'm
sure it'll look great but
man I just got done playing through God
of War on this like glorious OLED
television
looks so good man HDR and everything my
monitor's not HDR though or it is but it
just it's it's not very good on there
oh let's see go ninja thank you very
much for your continued support of the
stream though and then Jesse with a
super chat as well oh I didn't even see
that question Jesse before I just said
that we stream with the game releases on
February 7th I would love to see a
reaction excitement yeah yeah I'm going
to I've decided
and
I know previously we said that we were
gonna do twitch but right now
I'm about
95 sure I'm gonna do it on YouTube
because
I put up a poll on my Twitter
and I don't have my Twitter is not a
very big Twitter account I get way more
votes when I post on YouTube when I do
polls on YouTube I get a lot of votes on
there
but when I post on Twitter you know I
usually don't get too many votes this
one got I said when Hogwarts Legacy
releases where would you like me to
stream YouTube twitch and I realize the
majority of our audience is here but I
still didn't expect it to be 70 30 in
favor of YouTube 70 30.
so I'm like well I better listen to my
audience right
so I think we're I think we're gonna be
here I think we're gonna be here about
95 sure
but thank you Jesse uh for the uh chat
and then I hope you'll be here to join
us for that as well all right
we gotta switch we gotta switch over
let's go to our commentary View
that's what I call it here
because do you guys see this uh this new
video that dropped
how are you well this is on the
Wizarding World Paige
I don't know dude I feel like I've seen
a similar
I feel like I've seen a similar
thumbnail before welcome to Gryffindor
you know what they say about imitation
right it's a sincerest form of flattery
okay wait hold on where is
[Music]
I mean pretty close
right
no they're like dude we see
I'm telling you man that's what I've
been telling all my uh
Hogwarts Legacy Creator friends of my
guys uh make a video about dark magic
that's what people want to know about
dark magic
let's watch this it's only a minute long
it's probably gonna be stuff we already
know I feel like this is more for the
general audience but
why not right
while players may not be defined as such
through a formal morality system you
could be the witch oh my gosh dude this
music
it's getting me pumped man you can be
the Witcher wizard you want to be which
can include defining your choices and
actions as dark
uh yeah you think
you think
can I use the unforgivable curses
yes everyone will be able to use the
unforgettable curses and you can make
the decision to add them to your
repertoire why did it get so loud all of
a sudden oh my gosh
or not it is your choice if that is the
path you wish to follow
when in combat the unforgivable curses
has a set cooldown time to manage their
extreme power right right by purchasing
the deluxe digital Deluxe or Collector's
Editions you'll have access to the dark
arts pack which includes hold on you're
going too fast
the thestral mount and the dark arts
cosmetic set and the dark arts battle
arena
perfect additions for those choosing a
darker path
uh which judging by the views on those
videos seems like it's gonna be a lot of
people
does learning and using the unforgivable
curses make you a dark wizard
this may depend on the circumstances
under which you need them
a line between light and dark can
sometimes be thin so this could be what
you know the whole Sebastian quest line
how he's trying to use dark magic to
save his sister
hold on make sure I read that right does
learning and using the unforgivable
curses make you a dark wizard
yeah
interesting
very interesting
very interesting indeed
but yeah I just saw they posted that
like right before we were going Live
tonight
or division
excuse me
the 50 Super Chat what
what okay hold on before I get to that
one I need to shout out let's see Noob
with another Super Chat I lay claim to
the niffler oh my gosh everybody's gonna
start donating you guys you don't have
to do
you don't have to donate to get yourself
named we'll come we'll come up with
something
but we seriously we should we should try
to come up with something fun for like
how we decide to name
everybody
when we get our our magical beings
magical beasts in the game new Blaze
claim to the niffler Alicia's already
got the moon calf and I guess we can
have more right because we can breed
them so we could have multiple Moon
calves Jeremiah Robinson with a two
dollar Super Chat can I claim the graph
oh man people are actually doing it
they're actually doing it Jeremiah the
grab horn
I love it dude I love it it works for me
now I just have to remember this I have
to remember Alicia mooncalf Noob niffler
Jeremiah Graf horn and then we had Dylan
with the 10 tier one gifted memberships
guys
oh my gosh
this is crazy this is actually crazy man
you guys know like we could talk we
could talk about the the new trailer and
the new ASMR if you guys want right
oh my goodness man you guys are too much
you guys are too much Dylan thank you
thank you very much and welcome to Alice
reckon tour to those 10 new 10 new
members there
and then right after that we had let's
see uh I think these are the ones who
got the gifted Jace Keem I am silver Rob
The Wiz
welcome to housewrecking tour and in the
OR division ladies and gentlemen
a 50 Super Chat
just because you're awesome thank you
for motivating and giving a space to us
a space to share the love you're one of
the main reasons I became a Hogwarts
like this Creator it's been an amazing
ride and I thank you this community has
been great I'm glad to be part of it or
division dude
oh my gosh man you're gonna make me get
all you're gonna make me get emotional I
I posted a video let's see
let's see I posted a video how how long
ago was that
this video right
here
one of my best performing thumbnails
ever by the way
this video right here one of my best
performing thumbnails ever you know
didn't do crazy views
people that got mad saying it was click
bait I have a deer Hogwarts Legacy fans
I have an important message for you and
that whole point of that video
not to click bait anybody it was just
about enjoying this ride that we're on
not even just the hype man but but all
these friendships that we formed these
bonds like all the people hang out in
the Discord
there are some people who literally talk
every day now that we as in this whole
Community not just me but had like a
small part in helping bring together
which is man that's what it's all about
dude that's what it's all about
and for Aura division to say that I'm
one of the reasons they chose to become
a creator
it's awesome dude it's awesome so I wish
or division nothing nothing but the best
with your content I know you got a lot
you've been working on I saw you were
getting into some of the spoiler stuff
the other day which a lot of our folks
have tried to stay away from by the way
guys
if you have a comment deleted don't feel
bad don't let it hurt your feelings
we're just we're trying to keep a very
tight lid on the spoilers here because a
lot of people don't want to know a lot
of people did not want to know
so we're just being very careful with
that try and protect people
but or division again my friend thank
you very much too kind too kind
uh let's see zigster subscribed to the
channel thank you zigster and the nerdy
giant with a five dollar Super Chat
should we expect some special content
from you tomorrow
you should expect a Hogwarts like C
video tomorrow absolutely
absolutely just like we post Hogwarts
Legacy videos every week here on this
channel and yeah
one or more than one is dropping
tomorrow
and it's one you want to see it's when
he it's when you definitely want to see
yes indeed
one I've been working very hard on very
very hard on can't wait for you guys to
see it so last week I teased the um
I am still working on a story video I
want to do one more
like the lore slash story of like like
the pre-release story of Hogwarts Legacy
I want I still want to do that video
before launch
but I am quickly running out of time I
realize
and I know I teased that one last week
and then I just ended up releasing my uh
order the Phoenix let's play
but that one is still coming too that
one is still coming too but it that is
not the wizard that's coming tomorrow
five dollar Super Chat
but nerdy giant if I didn't say thank
you thank you very much my friend thank
you for your support uh Dustin with a
five dollar Super Chat that random
system used for gifting gifts the
Christmas stream
could be good for naming
but did we you oh it was it was a
nightbot yeah yeah it was a nightbot and
you just had to enter a command
we could do something like that yeah
I kind of feel like I wanna oh we could
I think we actually can restrict it to
Members Only
I'm pretty sure that we can I'm pretty
sure we can restrict it to Members Only
but yeah that's an idea
I just don't know like guys I honestly
have no idea what to expect for the
actual gameplay streams when we start
streaming the game live I have no idea I
I really don't man I don't know
I don't know how many people are going
to be here
I could see it being
less than half of what's here right now
but then I could also see it going up
because the game's like I just don't
know I feel like so many I mean the
majority of you are going to be playing
the game you're gonna be playing the
game now some of you may have me up in
the background while you're playing but
then it's like what if I get ahead of
you and you don't want it spoiled
I don't know but we're gonna stream it
and we will be here live
the Monday leading into the Tuesday
which they still haven't said
I'm PR I'm pretty sure that it's gonna
be like midnight Eastern people have
been like checking what PlayStation is
showing on the countdown and all that
and it's looking like it looks like New
Zealand and you guys in the UK Australia
it looks like you guys are gonna be
playing it first
if all of those countdowns are correct
Dustin thank you for the Super Chat
though and then bear thank you for
subscribing to the channel and then Noob
with another Super Chat Noob thank you
so much I want to see all your videos
what do you mean
[Music]
what do you mean you want to see all my
videos
like you want me to scroll through them
all that would take forever
that would take forever
yeah you guys like
I'm having a lot of fun with this new
thumbnail style I'm doing on the Let's
Plays I think I'm gonna go back and
change all of the old ones too to this
uh
like put my head on the box art for the
game
so I think I'm gonna do
Jay with a super chat 10 a.m eastern
time I got an A in divination I also
follow on Twitter so there's that AJ
thank you thank you for your support on
Twitter
10 AM is when I usually post videos
that's when I normally post videos
but not always
sometimes it's earlier sometimes it's
later
thank you Jay for the Super Chat
all right I've not gotten to talk to you
guys about the new trailer
I've not gotten to talk about it
with you all and and and I haven't even
made a video on it because I've been so
busy on the video that's coming tomorrow
been so busy on that video so let's
watch it right now let's watch it right
now together this trailer got me it got
me so hyped
new with another Super Chat new thank
you so much you said that the video
tomorrow is the one we want to see but I
want to see them all well I mean they're
already available to you so you could
have already seen them but if you I mean
if you want to watch them all again
I mean absolutely absolutely go for it I
mean like YouTube you guys know what
YouTube rewards more than anything else
is watch time watch time
so if you ever like oh there's a retro
video I'm gonna click it just to help
him out and then you leave like you're
like I was just doing that to help him
and then you leave it actually hurts the
video believe it or not
I know crazy right it hurts the video
because that sends a signal to YouTube
that oh man this video is not good that
person clicked on it but they didn't
like it maybe it was clickbaity but if
you like watch watch the videos for a
good length of time
then
YouTube's like oh snap that must be a
really good video you're a wizard let's
show it to more people you're a wizard
Harry you know who's a wizard is this
character right here it's about to get
shown
tabby cat gaming with a super chat as
well sorry but I will be playing uh but
I will watch them later I promise hey
thank you tabby cat like I'll be honest
I don't blame you I I don't blame you
it's if it's a new that's exactly what I
do if it's a new game that I'm really
like I really know I want to play it
like God of War that's the most recent
example for me
I since I have beaten the game I've been
going back now and watching a bunch of
the let's players that I enjoy
and streamers that I enjoy I've been
going back and watching their uh either
like their um some of them post to
YouTube and some of them don't but I've
been going back and watching some of
those
so yeah if you guys if you guys do come
back and watch it'll be it'll be very
much appreciated but yeah I don't blame
you when it's when that game hits man
I'd say the majority of you are gonna be
playing lowercase Logan with a super
chat another Super Chat from or wait
no
the first thing I missed was was I think
it was your uh your membership lowercase
Logan thank you so much for the Super
Chat is there the potential for a second
stream this week hope this doesn't break
your unbreakable vow uh yeah there's
always potential for that yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I'd love to stream again this week guys
would love to
would absolutely love to
have to see if I can make it work with
my schedule
Jordan cook thank you for subscribing to
the channel Jordan
and then Jake is in the house as well I
don't think I've read a single chat post
tonight guys I'm so sorry
I am so sorry
normally I get caught up with the chat
but like you guys are going crazy with
this with the super chats tonight man
a snake should be named Jake The Snake
oh hey that could work for you too right
I don't know how I always remember that
your name is Jake but it sticks with me
hi one two three High I bet new people
drop in and they're like what what's he
talking about there's nobody nobody
named Jake donated
Jake good to see you here my friend
thank you for the Super Chat
all right let's watch this uh this
trailer here it's a short one but it got
me hyped wait why is this part the most
replay of the whole trailer look at that
it's this new feature YouTube added if
you guys didn't know about this you can
kind of like hover over the timeline and
it'll show you where the the spike is
and where people dip
so people watch like the very beginning
and left or maybe they just were
rewinding a lot
all right let's do this
so this is this trailer really doesn't
show a lot that's why it's called like
cinematic trailer so
I could see this one airing on TV
commercials maybe I know they've already
been doing some many of you have been
telling me how you've seen them but it's
like it's one of those short and quick
trailers right it's it's more Broad in
fact there's some of the stuff that
we're going to talk about here that I'm
not even sure if it's
more like it's just this overall
cinematic feel right so
I have questions I have questions I'll
be curious to see what you guys think
too so we start off with the owl right
we'll just let it we'll just let it play
through and then we'll go back through
and stop I want to know who you guys
think this is I've seen all the
screenshots comparing I'll tell you who
I think it is
so we're in the allery send this owl
just so gorgeous
music the
they keep nailing it every time we hear
more music there's our boy Nick
all right we're gonna definitely freeze
it at that part
because I want to look at who all's in
that shot
come on come on
[Music]
I mean if this doesn't get you hyped
It's the Music Man the music makes it
[Music]
and then
is that our character you think that's
like the player character
your legacy begins now
Hogwarts Legacy live these handwritten
somebody tweeted me and said I thought
they were releasing it I thought they
were releasing it early because they say
your legacy begins now
you can find them all right so I'll tell
you this talking about who this could be
the second I saw that right there I
instantly thought of Mason from Han and
hogsmead instantly thought Mason
but most people are saying that it
sounds more like Professor Weasley
and that it doesn't sound like Mason
because why would May if if it is Mason
which
I still who I I'm kind of leaning toward
honestly take this find them why would
Mason be at Hogwarts
in the allery
not Weasley
or it could be someone completely
different
could be someone completely that we
don't even know right
foreign
and at first I thought
it's not at first I thought oh
acceptance letter but that is not how
they package the acceptance letters you
know they're in the envelope with the
seal this one they just roll up
take this find them find them she almost
sounds mad
take this find them
foreign
and then the music like it just gives
you that hint right that hint McGonagall
time traveling McGonagall
totally Mrs fig
oh my goodness white wolf
oh my goodness
hold the phone
so this is back to Fig's character card
if you guys remember on the character
card
left behind his aspirations of working
for the ministry magic to follow his
wife Miriam around the world as she
researched the seeming disappearance of
ancient magic fig eventually grew weary
of this Quest left her to continue on
her own while he took on the job so wait
she wouldn't be
oh I liked it for a second but I don't
see how that would work unless it's like
way in the past
when Miriam was killed during her
travels fig felt responsible because he
was not there a guild that haunts him to
this day he is determined to understand
why and how she died and to finish her
work so yeah she's the one who's been
investigating this whole disappearance
of ancient Magic
Chris huff and puff think it's Weasley
it is in the past that's true Professor
Baxter they could have done it different
back then
doesn't automatically rule out that it's
it still could be an acceptance letter
like the feel that you get from watching
the trailer is that it's an acceptance
letter right it feels like you know your
Journey Begins now it's trying to give
you that feeling of like you're getting
your letter
okay we've already watched that one
then we just get some gorgeous gorgeous
scenery here
not really a lot of new stuff in this
one
oh wait hold on I want to look at the
the banners
so you got Gryffindor Hufflepuff
Slytherin Ravenclaw the stained glass oh
the stained glass it's so good so good
man
the these windows right here
um
they did such a good job with those such
a good job with those and I if you
remember they used that same image on
the release date announcement
and it was a it was a night shot so good
love that image
we got a shot of Nick right there okay
this right here this right here
so Weasley we already talked about how
they they changed up her attire
from the previous trailers that we had
seen so now getting way more McGonagall
Vibes right
definitely getting the McGonagall Vibes
now if people think that first first one
is Weasley
I mean the black yeah that part matches
but these little uh the white part here
does not this looks like literally
exactly like like what Mason is wearing
like like exactly
but the voice I agree The Voice doesn't
sound
but
we've already seen things they've
changed I mean speaking of right
Weasley's attire we've already seen
they've changed things so
hmm I don't think that's I don't think
it's a lock either way then I don't
think it's a lock either way so we've
got Weasley right here
this is like James right here the
Hufflepuff and then we got uh heckit
and then let's see
just looks like some students here
it's a Weasley oh and they are all
concerned about something
and then so they're all so you got some
students in robes and then maybe these
are
yeah definitely uh to to Leah who said
it looks like an urgent Miss yeah it's
it's like
and it even sounds urgent there's a
sense of urgency in the voice you know
sense of urgency in The Voice
have a good one Cindy thank you for
stopping by and hanging out
Joe in the house oh my goodness Joe
Joe my friend
Joe and I always interact on Twitter I
hardly ever get to see Joe I don't think
the time usually works for Joe in the
streams
dude Joe Machado ladies and gentlemen
you've probably seen his I guarantee
you've seen his meme sometimes the
Reddit takes them and doesn't credit him
for the Hogwarts Legacy memes
oh my goodness Joe good to see you here
my friend this is the first time we hear
about ancient magic disappearing we see
it corrupted and we know it was hidden
but what else is happening to it right
and like is all this
is all this connected I know we're kind
of tying it back
we're tying it back into that card with
fig
which may not be the exact correct thing
to do but I mean there's like clearly
I'm not going to say they're panic but
like something's going on here that
they're they're asking what's up it
sounds very urgent right here
take this find them find them
thank you
I have another question about the letter
here in a second
foreign
building
so Weasley you can see she's like trying
to calm them down
we don't know what magic caused this
I think it's ancient magic Weasley
I don't know
I think
I think it might be ancient Magic
you guys think so
you think there's a decent chance
draconi yeah exactly
can anyone make out what it says on the
letter
yo Miranda Lori and what is up welcome
how's it going Miranda lorian
speaking of those uh those streamers
that I mentioned going back and watching
some of their uh let's plays
Miranda lorian recently platinumed God
of War guys recently platinumed it so I
was hanging out watching her stream the
other day
yeah so
definitely tension
and
also
do we actually somebody was saying about
the letter do we even see like can you
is there anything you can make out on
the letter
oh no it's rolled up are you talking
about when they open it maybe when they
open it
we don't know what magic calls this
take your magic Weasley I promise
all right this one right here glacias
so confirmed we had seen it in one of
the older trailers but again as they've
changed things
it could have it could have disappeared
as well I love the effect of it though
right there I hope it looks like that in
game because this this looks like all
I don't know if this is in game right
here
oh here's what I wanted to say about
this
some people have already pointed this
out to me left-handed wand
left-handed wand right there
which again we haven't seen the one in a
left hand yet we haven't seen it yet
Damon you Platinum did as well oh man I
gotta get on that I beat the game and I
want to go back in Platinum it I have
the platinum in in 2018.
Miranda Lauren if you're still here I
couldn't believe when you said that was
you said that was your first Platinum
right
I couldn't believe that
that was your first Platinum
Chris heffenpuff I was at work earlier
messaging nagura and just thinking to
myself
if you like any bugs just be explained
by ancient magic any power that they
need to explain right could be explained
by ancient magic for sure for sure
but I love this like visual effect
of glacias right here but yeah then the
wand in the left hand I'm still not
convinced
because we saw the one in the left hand
on the um
on the cover of the art book two
I I think like my my guess would be that
it's just a visual
like for the trailer
I hope I'm wrong I hope I'm wrong I hope
that that you can switch to the left
hand
but I know a lot of people probably saw
that and thought oh let anyone confirmed
I don't know yet I don't know I don't
think so
I don't think so
all right then we get these
[Music]
what does he say right here I'm gonna
turn on the captions
Majestic t with the Super Chat Majestic
T thank you for your support of the
stream love the Late Night Magic so
excited to finally play I know it's so
close
it's so close
yeah I guess this is kind of late for
some people I hear that a lot from the
UK audience they're like why do you
stream so late
sorry sorry
no Jake we haven't we haven't gotten to
the winter ASMR yet we're still going
through the the trailer here
how are you hey Cloud Roth
thank you for becoming a member here on
the channel
by the power of Thor's hammer you are
now officially a member of House rack
and tour my friend enjoy the emojis in
the chat
you get a special Discord roll
exclamation point Discord guys if you're
not already part of our Discord
and then you uh get discounts on merch
as well
3 A.M for Milan in the house oh my
goodness oh my goodness you guys are
crazy
you guys are crazy
I I'm a night owl too though I'm an idol
too I stay up pretty late
oh wait they called this glacio
or is that just a uh
wait what
you're a wizard
oh yeah he definitely says glacias but I
think it's just the caption
all right then right here
come on settle I said settle oh and then
huh
[Music]
so it's almost like
they know
they know that someone's trying to sin
you know what this made me think of this
made me think of
is it book seven
when is it they start worrying about the
owls getting intercepted
that's seven right
they they're all or maybe that even
starts in book three I think it starts
in book three
because
um
when Harry's like sending his letter to
Sirius
or it might be like book three book four
five you guys are saying
I feel like it starts for sure in book
four too though just in a different
context when Harry's trying to send it
to uh send stuff to sirius they're like
worrying about them getting
intercepted and stuff
oh most people are saying book five
though
oh wait hold up we had uh let's see am
with a super chat
blink twice if we'll see or if we'll see
gameplay tomorrow well I mean you've
already seen gameplay so yeah I mean if
you if you if you go on to the the
gameplay videos You'll see gameplay
tomorrow
of course of course there's a lot of
gameplay videos out there Hogwarts
Legacy
Kenzie thank you for subscribing to the
channel and then Chris Hufflepuff as
well with another Super Chat
guys thank you so much for the super
chats very much appreciated
um Chris so I usually post at 10 A.M
Eastern Time
but sometimes they can be earlier
sometimes they could be later so
yeah but I do have a yeah got some got
some Hogwarts Legacy content coming your
way tomorrow
coming your way tomorrow thank you for
the Super Chat though and then blue moon
or Blue Moon Blue Moon with the one
month subscription or no membership
letter starts out tied to the ankle but
ends in Talons I think that's a hint at
the video timeline being a misdirect
could be a misdirect or
or this is kind of where I was going
blue moon or it gets captured at some
point
and they like switch it out
they switch it for something different
or or maybe this owl is just like
amazing
maybe the owl's amazing and the owl gets
like hit by a couple spells
it becomes it loses it but then it just
has to end up picking it up
or it has it has to fight back against
the poachers attacking it but this is
where I was going with this this is
where I was going is that it reminds me
of when they were all having to worry
about the owls getting intercepted
they were having to worry about owls
getting intercepted so it seems like
whatever this message is here at the
beginning
find them
Hogwarts Castle is kind of on alert
they're all going to Weasley what's
going on
Lisa is like we don't know what caused
this then the poachers even are trying
to intercept this owl
so maybe they're intercepting all owls
right now or something I mean and he
just like he just straight up as soon as
he sees it
I mean I don't know who just randomly
wants to AK
oh and then you get the shot of the
meridian black dragon
[Music]
what a dedicated owl though right
what a dedicated owl and then it drops
the letter
to us in London
see Big Ben in the background
right there
okay now this is where I'm starting to
wonder
I'm starting to wonder oh wait hold on
did I miss another Super Chat I did from
our buddy Noob you're hiding something
I'm loving the response you gave to the
gameplay it was Perfection right yeah
of course she could see gameplay
tomorrow
it's already it's it's on the internet
guys it's
they did two gameplay Showcases of
course you could see gameplay you can
see gameplay right now
thank you Noob thank you for the support
my friend Dr sherbet stay hydrated and
eat you feel better I need to get some
chocolates what I need
my tea is totally cold now though I need
to go heat it back up
I'm not even a big tea drinker only
reason I'm even drinking it because I
have a sore throat
sore throat right now so that's why I'm
drinking it
and then we had uh let's see oh my gosh
Jay oh wait David was here David was
here with a super chat as well what if
the magic of acting Hogwarts is also
affecting all the animals and that's why
they're reacting the dragon and the
hippogriff
so
how are you we know they referred to it
as a corruption
corruption
and we see kind of that red around the
Goblins in particular and then the troll
scene the scene with the troll like
bursting out of the hogsmeade area you
see that kind of reddish
so I wouldn't be surprised yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if it's like I
don't know maybe just the magic whatever
this event is that they're talking about
that's triggered all of this
maybe it has both positive and negative
effects yeah I could see that and then J
with the five gifteds
welcome to Gryffindor I need to like
pay John Cleese to say welcome to house
wrecking tool
welcome to house record tour my friends
thank you guys thank you Jay thank you
for the gifteds and to all of you who
received a gifted right there make sure
you think Jay enjoy your emotes
enjoy your special Discord role
discounted merch if you guys want to
check out the merch we have things like
like the Hat there in the shop
and then uh go ninja go two dollar Super
Chat so tomorrow we'll see you on the
next Hogwarts Legacy gameplay LOL
you mean like another uh you mean like
another showcase or something
I don't think they're doing another
showcase I could be wrong could be wrong
but I don't think they're doing another
one
we shall see
I mean because we're what we're
literally we're two weeks we're two
we're two weeks today guys
so if there is one I mean it had to have
been filmed a while back
your legacy begins now okay here's
here's the other thing I want to talk
about this okay oh wait Jake only two
months to go until gold
wait what two months to go into gold
what are you talking about the game so
the current gen versions are already
gold they've gone gold
they're they're shipping in
actually I wonder if they I wonder like
what what the shipping status is you
know
foreign
did you go to Universal and if so how
was it I did yeah yeah I did
let's Universal in La posted a picture
of uh
me being at a Super Mario store
I was mad though because I couldn't get
into the um
I couldn't get into the Super Mario area
it was annoying
because it doesn't officially open until
next month in February I really wanted
to see that part but they do already
have like the little shops up
for the Mario stores so I did get to go
in those so that's where that's where I
got that picture
but yeah I I'd been to the um I'd been
to the one in Orlando before so this is
my first time checking out the one in in
LA
but thank you for the five months Jake
five months yeah I'm just not sure what
you mean about gold though or oh I bet
you mean I bet you mean the little um
oh my gosh you can tell how like my mind
is all about the release of this game
it's all about the release of this game
I thought you meant like the game going
gold you're talking about our little uh
what are they called
it's not Emoji it's the uh
the little icons that you guys have by
your name the membership icons whatever
they're called
all right let's see so we got Jay we had
Go Ninja
and then we had the grimly little paveo
or pavado
fails Aaron and hallberry with a three
months thank you so much
welcome to house wrecking tour My
Friends by the power of Thor's hammer
thank you guys for being here hanging
out volte with another Super Chat on
break what did I miss
you can actually rewind volte that's
actually a
I realize that sounds like I was being
kind of a jerk to you I didn't mean it
that way didn't mean it that way just
just rewind both just rewind no I was it
it literally made me think of one of the
annoying things whenever I stream on the
other platform or whether whenever I'm
watching people on that platform it
makes it hard to rewind
like if you're watching them live and
you want to go back it makes it hard but
here YouTube it's super easy you could
just if you want to pull back
so what I usually do
like I can never watch James's streams
right at 4 30 usually I'm usually a
little bit later than that so I'll hop
in there and I'll just put it on 2x
speed until I get caught up to where
they're at
but yeah you've missed uh we've been
breaking down the trailer and then Joe
Machado with the Super Chat as well Joe
thank you so much dude thank you for
supporting the channel here how was your
totally coincidental content creator
meet up last week her Tails parmesan
fries jealous
oh man yes I mean like James posted a
picture but like you guys
you guys have no idea when that was
taken is there like a time stamp on
pictures
no actually I think I think they're I
think there actually is a way right on
iPhones I think there is
no man it was great though Joe it was
great I did I did get to meet James for
the first time guys I got to meet James
and
just as like some people I've said this
about James before
you just like you just Vibe with them
you know like I have a lot of a lot of
friends acquaintances that you meet
but then there there are some that you
just like
you just buy with on another level and
like you can you can go long periods of
time without seeing each other and then
come back together and you pick up right
where you left off I have two friends
from high school exactly like that
exactly like that it's like it doesn't
matter we could literally not talk for
years and they could show up at my
doorstep tomorrow and we'd hang out for
hours and have a great time
but um but James man like just since
James and I started interacting through
this whole Hogwarts Legacy thing I kind
of felt that sort of similar similar
vibe there we just get along get along
very well
but yeah and then I I got to meet some
other people too
and it was uh it was similar similar
Vibes similar Vibes Joe but yeah thank
you for the Super Chat thank you very
much appreciate it
I know nutmeg right
James is going to jump in the chat and
be like I'm sorry retro I don't feel the
same way
oh my gosh no um I was watching actually
I missed this on James's stream those
are the regulars over there I'd expect
to go stream no one time he got asked
I don't know why somebody brought this
actually I think it was you Chris
I think it was you Chris Chris asked him
too
um you know they're like merry kiss kill
Game Chris asked him to do that and gave
him three
creators I can't remember who the other
two were one of them was me and James
said he would marry me of the three so
there you go there you go guys
oh and then Chris asked me the same
thing I'm pretty sure that was Chris
here I could be wrong
and then we had uh let's see another
Super Chat from volte glad you guys had
had a good time should have taken me
I'll let it slide
yeah it was it was a good time it was a
good time
okay so the thing I want to say about
this though the last thing I want to say
about this trailer
and remember it's a cinematic trailer so
I don't know how much we're supposed to
read oh now I realize why somebody was
saying can you read it
because you totally do
have a moment there
oh Joe I I feel like Joe's already done
this somebody has already zoomed in on
this and tried to break it down right
someone has already tried to break this
down I know they have
but here's what I want to know
because we had been assuming at least I
had I don't know what kind of the
conventional wisdom was
I feel like everybody had been assuming
that our character the main character
didn't know anything about
magic you can you can say something
my wife's like terrified for her voice
to even be on stream it cracks me up
we gotta get her we gotta get her one
day
we gotta get her one day to just she she
definitely I had to assure her I'm like
as long as you don't cross like this
point right here you won't be seen don't
worry
but she won't even say anything come on
wife wants a wizard try but you can't
see him gotcha well if wife wants a
wizard already tried and you can't see
then I'm not gonna waste any time doing
it not gonna waste any time because I
will trust wife once a wizard on that
but what I do want to say about this is
I was going under the assumption that
our character was like completely new to
Magic
that for whatever reason parents a lot
of people are saying maybe the parents
died maybe we cause something to to
cause our parents to die something to do
with ancient magic possibly
but like the realization first of all
they're in London wearing okay no
they're not wearing like Hogwarts robes
but watch watch the reaction
I mean it yes it's one of surprise
but they clearly they seem to know what
it is
whereas Harry was just like
he's got a half giant showing up in his
house or not in his house but chasing
him all around
so that when I feel like circumstances
were different so again this was like
the part I don't know if we're just
supposed to read into it as like this
isn't even the character the main
character for the game this is just this
is just to get you to feel like you're
getting your welcome letter to Hogwarts
it very well could be that
but you guys already know that that's
not what we do here we take everything
we take we take a minute 19 and we turn
it into
like a two-hour stream that's what we do
that's what we do
thank you
she didn't even say you're welcome she
just gave me like a little uh thumbs up
she was reheating my tea for me very
nice super very nice of her
but yeah it feels like they
almost like they're first of all they're
not even
confused that there's an owl dropping a
letter to them
they see it they catch it
open it up
that dawn of realization what
but they they know what it is Legacy
begins now
Hogwarts Legacy live the unwritten
huh
dude
so good man all right we had a couple
more things we had a couple more things
dropping in here
let's see Apollo with Super Chat thank
you very much Apollo so making me expect
a new video for me retro tomorrow
new video tomorrow
sexy videos every week
this week it just happens to be
Wednesday
you're a wizard
so yeah stay tuned man excited for you
guys to see it
really excited for you guys to see it
and then we had
volte okay
volte with 1.99 Super Chat to say I'll
give her a 4.99 if she talks on stream
no she's she works in the medical field
they pay too much overtime volte
she could just be like I'll pick up an
extra
an extra shift
I don't think we can persuade her that
easily
don't think we can Stella and then Chris
welcome thank you guys for subscribing
to the channel
thank you very much for subscribing all
right winter ASMR
this one will kind of be able to just
play in the background you know
oh wait wrong one wrong one
right here right here
here we go
20 minutes so I we had a we had a poll
in the chat if you guys didn't vote in
the poll yet make sure you vote before
you leave also thank you guys for all
the likes crazy number of likes we're
over 200 now we're gonna make sure that
we whenever we hit 100 likes here on the
stream we do a random bit of Harry
Potter quote trivia stick around for
that and then right after that we will
do a impression from the Harry Potter
series you guys pick the character
and we'll go from there
we'll go from there so I knew going in I
knew this one was going to be my
favorite by far I knew it would
and it is it is I just I love everything
about it
everything about it
for those of you who weren't here at the
start of the stream I uh talked about my
love of winter scenes and games
they're just so fun
just so fun some of my favorite levels
in all video games
Apollo thank you for the Super Chat
Apollo what time tomorrow gotta make
sure I'm around
so my video tomorrow is going live at
9am the Hogwarts Legacy video that I
have planned for tomorrow
is 9 A.M Eastern Time
unless
something changes right now that's my
plan that's my plan
Noob with a super chat as well you
should tell wife reckon tour I said
hello oh Shia she
she knows she watches a lot of times
she's she lurks mostly
Dustin says 10 more gifted memberships
for a while white racket tour wave like
you guys just see her hand like appear
if you're watching Mrs Dragon tour they
probably think you don't even exist that
I'm just like making you up this whole
time the kids they're not real either
all of it I just like I just made it up
I actually live alone the dog is real
you guys see me show the dog on camera
thank you uh Dustin thank you
am sent a Super Chat as well we see
Professor Weasley in the in the
classroom so she can't be in two places
at once
true true unless
well
Time Turner
because in the World of Harry Potter we
know that is that is how it works in the
time turn like in the World of Harry
Potter
that's why I really hope the game
doesn't do time travel
because it's just so complicated
maybe they could pull off in a video
game a little bit better but like I I
prefer
I don't want to go down this Rabbit Hole
too deep of time travel
because I just generally dislike time
travel of any kind in stories I liked it
the most like I like it how producer of
Azkaban handled it because it's what you
call a closed loop
a closed loop so what that means is that
the loop is closed there's not like an
infinite number of possibilities that's
that spanned as a result of Harry and
Hermione going back
we're not talking about cursed child
we're not going to get into cursed child
focusing on the original books
uh so like that scene you know when they
go back to save Buckbeak
they're actually physically in two
places at the same time
so if the game really wanted to do it
they they could what I think
is if it's Weasley which again I'm still
not convinced it is but if it's Weasley
I think the more likely possibility is
that
it's just like different different times
you know like I don't think it's
necessarily chronological like maybe
that scene that we see with the teacher
with Weasley being like we don't know
what caused this maybe then she goes
rolls rolls up her sleeves and sends the
owl
so I don't think it automatically means
that it's happening in chronological
order
at the exact time
I'm just dead yeah it's it's all been a
lie guys I'm a fake I'm a fraud
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
actually not a father I'm not a father
believe it or not
whomping willow waiting this did you
guys see a woman
oh it could be
I don't think so
but but possibly
so I made a video on this a while back
and people were jumping all over me
because they didn't watch the video
they were jumping in the comments it's
like guys you didn't even watch and
actually listen to what I was saying you
didn't listen to what I was saying
so the Whomping Willow from the Harry
Potter Harry Potter's day would not have
been planted in this time we know that
that's for sure however it's there's not
only one whopping Willow that exists
there could have been others
there could have been others so for a
long time in that um
actually I still think
yeah yeah it's it's like in the shot
the box art and the wallpaper of that
over on the right side of that image
I thought that looked like a wobbling
Willow and I still think it could be a
whomping willow could be
Christopher thank you for subscribing to
the channel
stairway here from The Boathouse up to
Hogwarts
I just like seeing all of this
I just can't wait to explore this man I
just can't wait to explorers to be able
to walk around all these little areas
think about all these little sections of
the ASMR that we have seen
I can't wait dude I can't wait to get in
there and explore and look for all the
little secrets
all the little secrets that are hidden
Within
and what a great
I don't know who who came up with the
idea
to do like the ASMR I'm trying to turn
up a little bit more because I feel like
it's so quiet
unless we destroy a whopping Willow
there probably won't be one ooh maybe we
could though
maybe we could
I think it'd be cool if there was a
Whomping will in the game just because
it's like
it's one of those iconic pieces of
you're a Wizarding World lore
a fighting tree you know a tree that
that fights back
foreign
into Hogwarts there
it comes the stool oh you talk about the
little bench up there
oh man
we did a poll on that about sitting
because I'm in the camp that I don't get
why people care
and I think was it almost I feel like it
was almost 50 50.
I feel like it was like 53 47 or
something
yeah I think it could be that tree that
we see in the wallpaper I think it could
be a whomping willow like of that
species of tree
all right so let's take a look at the
poll and see if uh winter is still
see if winter is still winning
uh hold on how do I keep playing this
and not hide there we go
oh my gosh winter is absolutely
destroying I'm gonna I'm gonna get ready
to end the poll if you haven't had a
chance we had 874 votes 875 so here it
is guys the uh we asked favorite ASMR of
all the ones they've released 70 spring
15 summer 19 fall
49 winter
a little bit of recency bias just maybe
Maybe
there you go there's the final results
but I agree I agree even not recency
biased though like if this had been the
first one it would have been my favorite
just because I love
oh like that right there
oh man so good
so good we are almost at 300 likes by
the way if you guys haven't hit the
thumbs up button and you're enjoying
your time here in the Stream make sure
to hit the thumbs up before you go
really helps other people find this
video those of you who are watching this
later in the replay Squad
#replay Squad in the comments below let
me know let me know
well hey Randall thank you for this oh
wait did I miss Apollos
oh I did hold on Christopher and Zach
thank you for subscribing if I missed
those my apologies and then we also had
Apollo with another I think that's
Apollo's second yeah it is Apollo's
second Super Chat thank you very much
Apollo
uh speaking of Secrets did you catch the
secret in the Hufflepuff common room in
showcase one or the map of argolshire
what so what's the secret you're talking
about from showcase one I mean because
we definitely broke it down
a lot
and then Randall with a super chat as
well how about a video at 1201 am nah
don't expect a video then
I should experiment with that sometime
so YouTube claims
YouTube claims that time of day that you
post a video that they have found from
their research it doesn't make any
difference on the uh like the ultimate
success of a video
which probably makes sense
maybe just like that initial boost
sometime if you post at a YouTube gives
you some really interesting Graphics
though like I can go in and see
it's like these little um
horizontal bars
and they'll be color coded and the ones
that are like a darker purple
that's when the most of my viewers are
online
and so it'll tell you like when the
majority are online it's pretty cool
but yeah 12 1201 is not um
not part of it
Apollo again with a super chat
Apollo thank you thank you dude
take a look at the mini map
oh you talk about in the uh
Hufflepuff common room showcase
oh gotcha oh or the map of argul Shire
maybe that's what you're talking about
Austin just curious if getting hit with
the killing curse in-game is Auto game
over or if it will have some kind of
plot armor oh
I like that question
you're a wizard I feel like
will we know from the from the combat
so you get the little yellow indicator
that's the ones you want to Parry you
get the red indicator those are the ones
you need to dodge out of the way from so
AK would definitely be in that cam you
can't protego it
cannot protego
I I feel like it would be insta
which is
is crazy if that's if that's how they
handle it
oh man
I hadn't thought about that though
because everybody's been asking about
the opposite like is it two op for our
character like how's it going to work on
bosses because we've seen they just
completely obliterate the troll right
just just one shot the troll with AK
and so on our side it has the slower
cooldown but what is it like for the
enemies
and I think I saw Thomas said it was
their first time here Thomas thank you
for being here
and welcome welcome to the Stream
uh there are Auto saves right probably
go back to the last saved Place yeah I
guess so
maybe that's more like of a later game
thing when when enemies start casting
AKA against you
a Loki gamer watching liking commenting
on all of our Hogwarts creators tomorrow
hey thank you Loki gamer
yeah very much appreciated very much
appreciated guys
the likes the comments they go a long
way but more than anything like just
just watching the video really
what I said earlier when you just watch
videos all the way through
that is like the best signal of anything
to YouTube that you enjoyed the video
I mean think about it think about how
often you actually finish a video I
think about my viewing habits how often
I finish videos on YouTube
it's like especially if you're going if
there's like one thing you want to know
you go you find it and you leave
but the ones that you stay to the end
for
are the ones that you don't even realize
that it's like oh it's over you're
almost upset that it's ended
I try to I I TR every time I make a
video that is what I strive to do I
strive to make people get to the end and
not even to know the end is coming to
just be so enjoying the video that they
haven't even checked to see how much
time is left
and when it ends it leaves you wanting
more that's that's what I I shoot for
every time
yeah we'll have to try to take a look at
that mini map here in a second
um I'm gonna play on PS5 Taylor yeah
the PS5
my PC would run it and probably run it
pretty well
but for as far as content goes I mean
well to be honest I'm mostly a
PlayStation gamer anyway
um but especially for Content I want to
be able to have access to the uh haunted
hogsmead and all that stuff
oh that's an interesting idea Michael
maybe our ancient magic protects us from
from AK
I don't think they'll go that far I I
just like I think it'll just that'll
just be it you know like game over you
go back to the last save point
oh dude imagine if like one of the Final
Bosses in the game it's like they're
just
they cast a lot of AK
don't think the hospital Wing can repair
the killing curse I know right
[Music]
answer J and M's Super Chat
I did I did answer their super chats
your impressions should be Luna would
you like some pudding I don't even
remember that line
don't even remember that line
DD how long I've been into Harry Potter
I've been into Harry Potter since
before the movies were even made I was
I want to say it was right before I'm
I'm like a long time Potter fan it was
before
it was even before prisoner was out in
the U.S
I have even been before chamber but
those three came out
in pretty rapid succession
but yeah I've told the story a couple
times on stream I
saw it in a Scholastic book order
literally the whole don't judge a book
by its cover that's exactly what I did I
thought that cover looks awesome
read the description and thought I want
to see if the library has that
they did
or maybe even
I didn't buy it I didn't buy it right
away I didn't buy it from that
or no I did I think I did buy it in the
Scholastic Book Fair and the rest was
history the rest was history fell in
love
you're a wizard Harry I mean just almost
immediately almost immediately
so yeah man I was like I was watching
long before her reading long before it
even thought about being made into a
movie
you're famous 2012. in UFC
what are you famous for
Rodrigo I think AK should have the same
impact as the troll slam instant death
oh just a troll does it does it Insta
insta death
I can't remember that part
I'm so far behind
Neil wonder if we can become a ghost
imagine that's like the end game our
character dies and then
for you to
remember how people have been wondering
what's the end game you know because
almost all open world games do this
right where you can go and explore
afterwards finish up all the
Collectibles they either put you back
like right before the final mission
imagine if that was how Hogwarts did it
you lose access to like everything but
you could you can you could go through
walls so you can go and collect
everything but you're just a ghost
maybe there's like a Dev uh
that you know what that sounds like that
sounds like a really awesome cheat cheat
code idea
too bad cheat codes aren't even like a
thing anymore
at least not a lot
Jay all I did was ship him and James oh
yeah yeah I did see that I did see that
retro go I should hey I like retro go I
love it
we know the game is set in the 1890s
note the table runners and braziers
shaped like the house animals oh
yeah I'm still the date you guys
I think
either they changed it or
so remember in the first it was in the
reveal trailer right right where it says
September 1890
I think they might have changed it
because of what
of what um Troy said about the whole
chudley cannons thing they didn't take
it out
they didn't take out the chudley Cannons
thing
hey King everyone on New Game Plus
after tomorrow we have a behind the
scenes or how how that came about be
interesting to see
we'll have more Hogwarts Legacy content
coming your way
as you guys know
as you guys already know lots of
Hogwarts Legacy content in the lead up
to Launch
so gonna be a demo I have no idea
that's a good question though do you
guys would you guys want a demo
would you want a demo of Hogwarts Legacy
wizard tricks what is up wizard tricks
welcome dude thank you for being here
love the vibe stream is fire a thank you
dude thank you very much man appreciate
you stopping by and hanging out
yeah would you guys actually
would you want
should we do a new poll question let's
do a new poll question
I'm genuinely curious about this
genuinely curious oh wait no not a q a I
want to do a poll
would you want to see a
Hogwarts Legacy demo before launch
yes or no
boom
not this close I mean yeah we are pretty
close
two weeks two weeks for early for the
three day early access
two weeks
oh my gosh can you guys believe that oh
did we already get to the end of it all
right well we're gonna watch it again
we didn't even really talk about it
is to the out of that
thumbs down is good for the algorithm
I've heard that too Draven I don't know
for sure
but
what I've heard is that
the algorithm just that the algorithm
any kind of interaction is good
interaction
that even a thumbs down is like a signal
of
like if a video has 80 downvotes I can't
imagine that it's
gonna be rewarded for that you know
but I have I have I actually have no
idea about the downvotes I've studied a
lot of YouTube but but I have heard
exactly what you said though that like
hey it's engagement
I feel like as long as it's not just
like overwhelming down votes then it
honestly probably does help you because
it's like an additional thing that
somebody somebody felt it at least made
an impact on them enough that they
wanted to click an extra button
I think I heard Hogwarts Legacy you'll
have four save files like the Lego Harry
Potter game so everybody can have one
file for each house yeah that's what
they said on the uh WB Games support
or it may have been the port key games
one there's been so much you guys if you
go to uh wizard phd's Twitter account
she actually did a huge thread took all
this information that came out over the
past few weeks that they were answering
and she put it into a big long thread on
Twitter so at wizard PhD on Twitter even
if you don't have Twitter you can still
go and look at her uh look at that page
and I want to say that was
I want to say they they def I know they
for sure had the save files in there but
I think then they also said something
about they had even more auto save slots
so yeah you're gonna have you're gonna
have multiple safe slots for sure
I don't think New Game Plus is confirmed
yeah I haven't seen anything about a new
game plus
but I feel like I mean
be crazy not to right
crazy not to
newspaper could have been an older print
or they just even straight up changed it
feathers
or they just straight up changed it
which we've already seen them do with
some other things we've seen them do it
maybe maybe guys not even uh
maybe not
I don't know how
that would be a pretty significant one
because literally all of our theories
like have so many things about our
theories we've been basing around that
date I think the only thing they've said
for sure is late 1800s
maybe even
maybe even late
now I think it's just late 1800s and
then that spot we saw on the uh
on the newspaper
Zach did you I hold on I did not I don't
see a super chat from Zach
did it not pop back up
I saw somebody saying I didn't answer
Zach super chat but I don't even
oh there it is there it is there it is
if it is a school invite why do we get
it in winter
oh
good call
and I did miss that that happened right
that happened right in between
so sorry Zach so sorry dude thank you
very much for the Super Chat
I think yeah I mean I think that just
about confirms it then right that just
about confirms that it's not related to
it's not a an acceptance letter
which we didn't think um unless they
just sent it at like
a weird random time because something
has to happen with our character right
we know they're starting in abnormal
circumstances the fact they're starting
as a fifth year very very abnormal
and we don't know why
we think it's probably related to the
ancient magic we just don't know that
for sure it could be for a different
reason
so yeah though the fact that they
get it in winter
that's a great point
that's a great point I mean and I even
said first thing like it's not in the
traditional Hogwarts envelope with like
the red wax seal
so I uh yeah
that's a good one
and again very sorry that I missed that
it was 25 minutes ago hold on I'm gonna
make sure I didn't miss any more because
somebody said I missed someone else's
so then I saw I know I saw noobs about
tell
Mrs recenter said hi Dustin said 10 more
gifted then am said we see Professor
Weasley in the classroom she can't be
two places at once so we talked about
that one
speaking of now Apollos I did see we
just didn't pull it up yet about the um
the Hufflepuff common room in the first
gameplay showcase
take a look at the minimap yeah we'll
we'll try to remember to go and do that
here then we had uh several
subscriptions coming in there
and then we also had oof Dead with the
Super Chat that one was about nine
minutes ago I'm so very sorry oof dead
so very sorry that I missed that hey
retro been a long time fan glad I made a
live hey glad you made it live as well
dude I always love it when people get to
make the live streams who never had a
chance before because uh it's just like
it's just a different vibe you know it's
a lot more interaction we do this every
Tuesday evening I'm hoping to add more
in the future
hoping to add a lot more streams and if
I am able
to do what I'm hoping
but I'm hoping I could start doing more
like that aren't so late at night
which I'm still I mean I feel like this
is our goat I have to keep this time for
the foreseeable future for at least one
stream a week but thank you very much
for the chat I'm glad you got to stop by
and hang out for a stream and then we
also had Shiloh subscribe to the channel
uh Draco with a super chat as well how
excited are you for tomorrow
now see there's a good question
there's a good question Draco I love it
I'm like
it's like Christmas Eve dude it's
Christmas Eve
that's and as a kid growing up Christmas
is one of my favorite holidays
that's how I feel that's how I feel
Draco
that is how I feel
and then we had blue moon with a super
chat as well draw a distance of these
scenes is so beautiful right
right and then thank you Blue Moon also
catching up with uh Zach's
Super Chat as well yeah I don't know how
that one just completely like got
sandwiched in between two others
you know what Zach since I missed it let
me see if this we're gonna test this
let's see if this
see if this works
there you go we pop it up again
pop it up again Zach Donato ladies and
gentlemen
there we go
and then we just had Let's see we got
Draco we got Blue Moon Blue Moon thank
you very much again for a Super Chat and
then Jay Felix I think that's another
one for Jay too we may not start at the
beginning of the year
I've always wondered that Jay because
they say that we start late
which a lot of people just took as oh
late late as in you're starting as a
fifth year
but what if you actually started this
school year itself late
hmm I don't I feel like it's got to be a
full school year
I feel like it's got to be one full
Hogwarts school year
but we definitely arrive if if the
carriage shot is the same
right in in the reveal trailer
we're in the carriage with fig
we don't seem to be arriving at Hogwarts
via the Hogwarts Express
and it's night it's also night
when they arrive and then in addition to
that welcome to Griffith we do get
sorted
like does it look like everyone else is
getting sorted too
well we know it's at least a full year
welcome because they've got four seasons
in the game
we know that for sure
[Music]
and oh my gosh hold up what just
happened
J okay uh Josh
renewed their membership Josh thank you
for becoming a channel member by the
power of Thor's hammer here welcome to
house wrecking tour and then we had
Dylan gifting out 10 memberships
holy cow Dylan thank you so much dude
oh I actually think Josh was one of the
gifteds Josh was one of the gifted so we
had Logan butter beer kalis Ethan
Barbara Brock Luis binto Olimar 92
Olimar recognized that name trippy Moon
and then BUDK and also silver 2233 guys
welcome to house wrecking tour my
friends enjoy your emotes enjoy the
special role in the Discord uh if you're
interested in our merch at all you get a
discount now like this retro hat right
here if you guys are wondering where I
got this shirt so this is not the shirt
is not my Merch this is official
Hogwarts Legacy merch guys you can get
these on Amazon
they have a a lot of Hogwarts Legacy
merch that just showed up
Amazon affiliate link down in the
description if you guys are interested
you can use that link and it'll help uh
it'll throw a little bit my way to help
out the channel at no extra cost to you
um but yeah they got some cool stuff in
there I ordered this one it says uh live
the unwritten at the bottom then it's
got the the wand from the collector's
edition I think most people are just
calling it the ancient magic wand
Hogwarts Legacy at the top super soft
love the print is pretty good except for
like the Hogwarts Legacy is a little bit
blurry I don't know if that was just
mine or if they're all like that I mean
it's still readable but everything else
like all this down here is great it is
so comfortable though man like hoodies
this type of like this zip up right here
zip up hoodies literally my favorite
thing to wear
my favorite thing to wear
but they have a lot more than that I got
this one and then I also got just the
the standard black and then it's got
like the Hogwarts Legacy uh logo it's
just like a black T-shirt
so they got some cool stuff there
and then uh let's see but Dylan my
goodness my friend thank you very much
Dylan I think this might be my one of my
favorite shots of any ASMR
of any of anything like that stained
glass I just I love it so much I love
I've always been a fan of stained glass
like in real life too like old really
old churches and cathedrals
it's just such a cool like Visual and
then how they make it is even more
insane like if any of you've ever been
to a glass Museum or something like that
see how they they do some of this stuff
it's awesome
so that I I think that shot right there
might be my favorite one in the whole uh
of all the asmrs it really might be
although I don't I don't get any snow in
this one I mean look then you get the
you get the the sky right there
uh Dante thank you for subscribing to
the channel and then Rossi what is up
Rossi
I always see Rossi
Rossi is first in so many of our videos
so many of our videos like commenting on
the videos on the channel
shout out to you Rossi
or is it Rosie have I been pronouncing
it wrong this whole time
have I been pronouncing it wrong this
whole entire time
oh my goodness and then I saw see I
gotta figure out
whenever people
post like they're you guys also get like
a little highlighted message or Whatever
Whenever you renew your membership and I
think I saw one from Christy earlier and
it's totally gone there it is
I finally found it Christy that was
probably from like an hour ago I'm so
sorry Christy with the four months
woohoo four months of amazing people
Harry Potter chats and Good Vibes indeed
Christy and more to come more to come
ah
but um but yeah shout out to Rossi who
also their Super Chat was blink twice oh
gosh blink twice if you've played
Hogwarts Legacy already and also what's
going on tomorrow
okay hold on we read the read the
question
all right so what's going on tomorrow is
uh I mean for me I'm posting a new
Hogwarts Legacy video
as we do every week as we do every week
guys
and I'm really excited about the one
coming coming out tomorrow real excited
about it
and I think you will be too I think
you'll enjoy it
I think you will enjoy tomorrow's video
very much
very much so but yeah guys
save your save your super chance
save your money
um we started off the stream talking
about unbreakable vows you remember
remember those in the Harry Potter
series yeah yeah very very serious these
unbreakable vows very serious
so I just you know
just felt like that would be a good
thing to bring up tonight for no no
particular reason I'm Rick wolves man
they're serious things
so uh but yeah Rossi
yeah
we'll see if we'll see if you're first
Rossi we'll see if you're first on
tomorrow's video
we will see
Rossi I'm telling you I don't know how
Rossi does it it doesn't matter it's
like a let's play if it's a Hogwarts
video if it's uh whatever
Ross is like first
you got it again you got it again
do you know how many you have Rossi do
you know like how many uh
you did Omar yeah yeah you were talking
about your name earlier
we were talking about your name earlier
Rossi
let's see
oh my gosh little paval paveo thank you
so much for the Super Chat just found
your channel not that long ago after
getting hyped for the game Habit to
support a great Creator and a family man
keep up the great work hey thank you
very much
thank you so much little pavao Pavo
pavao
I'm so sorry if I'm uh if I'm
mispronouncing it
but yeah family family's super important
super super important to me I um for
those of you who may be new to the
community we keep the streams family
friendly our Discord is family friendly
as well so I mean PG
PG-13 maybe a little bit in the Discord
but I I have like an eight-year-old and
a four-year-old and what I have always
said is I wouldn't want them I would
want them to be able to like sit over my
shoulder as I'm talking to people in our
Discord and not
not be uncomfortable and me and I have
to be like oh gosh same thing for the
live chat which the mods do a great job
with that so you know we're all most of
us are adults here so it's like yeah I
know the the language thing is kind of
weird but we we keep the family
keep the stream clean keep it family
friendly
and that's you know that's just who we
are that's just who we are and it's it
will always going to be that way so if
that's what you enjoy then
Good Vibes and positivity welcome
welcome
so I'm so glad you found the channel and
then Dustin
oh my gosh Dustin with another five
dollar Super Chat you said it's like
Christmas Eve and Christmas can be all
about giving so all the super chats
Dustin you already gave more than enough
you gave more than enough on our
Christmas celebration stream
more than enough on the Christmas
celebration
but thank you very much Dustin
appreciate it as always my friend Dustin
are you like I mean do you are you
trying to be a mod or something
do you need do you want something like
can I can I
I'm kidding I'm kidding
Dustin thank you so much though dude
it's always uh always good to see you
and again like if you guys if you have
the
the extra funds and you choose to throw
them our way here it is it is very much
appreciated but just know because I know
a lot of times people the donations are
fun I mean they are guys I'm not gonna
lie it's fun like it's hype everybody
loves the gifteds you love seeing it all
come in
I know several of the people here who
donate like
they're good they're good
but I know there's also a lot of you out
there struggling there's a lot of people
out there who especially right now you
know with I don't know what the economy
is like in across the world but you know
particularly in the US it's uh it's been
kind of Rocky
so please never feel like if you're not
a member that you're not like part of
the same team here
um please never feel like you have to
donate
honestly just the you being here you
being here Nico Nico will tell you Nico
is one of our longest
supporters of retro racket tour the
brand whatever you want to call it he
will tell you
how many years ago was it Nico let's see
it was like
it was pre-2020
so I mean it would have been like 2017
or so
up through 2020. we would stream on
Twitch you're a wizard Harry usually
three nights a week
to about
four or five people
you're a wizard for years
for years you guys I kid you not for
years years
and now I just pulled up right now right
now literally at this moment we're I
don't know how many hours we are into
the stream we got 422 people here
watching right now
422. you're a wizard Harry oh my gosh we
got a lot of new Wizards Harry
so
never if you're somebody sitting like oh
my gosh I wish I could donate to support
retro
do not feel
do not feel that obligation
because you're supporting literally just
by being here literally by watching the
videos you're supporting
sorry just had to say that man because
this this night is being crazy like
there have been I I don't know what's in
the air tonight you guys are just like
being super generous tonight but it is
uh
yeah it's been it's been very very
generous with the super chats
and the memberships tonight so thank you
all very much and then Zach with another
Super Chat coming in
as we as we talk about the super chats
thank you Zach again take my money cause
I'm confused if we get Weasley
I'll back up but just play this again
this is just so uh
we could get some music going again too
I'll just let this play I'll just let
this play right now
make sure it's all the way up though
yeah it is
if we get Weasley invite in winter per
the trailer we either start the year in
Winter or that letter is something else
I think it's something else
or
I mean the feel of the trailer it's
definitely trying to make it feel like
oh this is your letter to Hogwarts you
know you're opening it up to get your
acceptance letter you react surprise
that's why I'm not even sure if we're
supposed to be reading into it as much
as we are
because I could totally see it just
being like a generic
well no no no because we get the scene
with Weasley
and they know how we are they they know
how we are they know that we take a
minute 19 trailer and do this kind of
stuff
so they would they do that to us they
might actually they might just like
throw us a total red herring
hmm
wait when do
that's what I think will I think it's
just I think it's just an important
letter
and I think it's related to the whole
whatever the ancient magic stuff that
Weasley's talking about
well she does it she claims she doesn't
know we don't know what magic calls this
we know Weasley we know what's causing
it
trust me we know
that'd be how hilarious would it be if
it's like oh it's actually it was
something else
it's not the ancient Magic
all right let me see some some comments
Brett you already got your pre-order in
nice nice
the hype the hype's definitely in the
air
the hype is in the air
and the hype is about to just like
it's about to just launch to another
dimension
uh it'd be cool if Hogwarts Legacy ends
at the start of our seventh year when
Dumbledore is sorted Austin says we'll
see if we're that's the other thing
about the date Austin
if they change that date
from the first trailer
then we could be all wrong about when
Dumbledore comes in
we could be all wrong he could literally
already be there
depending on when the date is
depending on when the actual date is
I don't think he's going to be there I
think they're going to stay away from
the very established characters such as
Dumbledore
but if that if that single date change
it doesn't change like all of our
predictions but it's as far as like the
timeline goes yeah I mean that that
would change a lot
for what happened and when
oh
you think so too Leah yeah something
else I think so Zach I just think I
think it's probably something else
related to
and the way she's like the whoever I
still think it looks like Mason doesn't
sound like Mason but says find them
and they're not happy they're not happy
it's not like a Hogwarts letter
not a Hogwarts letter Josh can't speak
for everyone I feel like it's been a
long journey it has Josh
you amongst other YouTubers kept this
community in the hype going well thank
you Josh yeah
I've Loved I've loved the whole ride
I've loved every minute of it I uh
hey Dylan thank you man have a good
night
have a good night
people keep telling me the dad who loves
games people keep telling me they want
me to bring it back
to to the start of the videos
maybe I will but I gotta I gotta keep it
quick gotta keep it quick we can't have
these big long 30 second intros like I
used to
YouTube doesn't like the big well people
don't like the big log intros because
they click away if they don't if they
don't know us if they're not like in the
know like all you guys they just bounce
they're gone who is this guy you know
Dad who loves games I don't care they
leave
so gotta be gotta be Snappy with the
intros
uh let's see
what else do we have pretty sure it's
Weasley yeah somebody else said that
earlier laughingstock that it could be
uh
Fig's wife as well but why why do people
I love that idea at first but then we
went back and read the character card of
fig and it talks about how
he goes back to Hogwarts
so like she's unless that was set in a
very different time
which it could be it could be
and welcome to the uh
to the new subscribers we just had
several new subscribers also Jake
with the Super Chat can you tell us who
is in the top five for memberships Oh
you mean like the longest ones
there's there's got to be a way to look
for that
Jake
it's very easy on Twitch but I don't
know
I don't know if it's easy on YouTube or
not let's
I don't want to waste a lot of time but
I will uh
I'll poke around here for a second
there's one there's one place I'm gonna
check and if it's not there
then we'll uh we'll have to save that
one for later
okay here we go memberships
it shows me recent member activity
oh we we total time is a member oh it
does show me
it does show me oh my goodness dude
I can't believe it feels like so much
longer than this you guys feels like so
much longer so the longest member
is our boy Dylan who just who just left
had to head out for the night our boy
Dylan has been a member for six months I
feel like it's been neat I feel like
it's been years since I've been talking
to you guys
Dylan six months then right behind him
we have a bunch of five month people
we got Nico
we've got Jason Ingram we got
machop172 we got cat dad TV and we got
Jake so interesting a balance there of
frequent Chatters and then also people
who don't maybe don't chat as much
wow that's that's cool so I guess Dylan
as as long as Dylan stays consistent no
nobody will ever be able to overtake
Dylan no one ever will be able to
overtake him unless he ever misses a
month if he missed a month
if he ever missed a month then some of
you five month people or five yeah five
month people could catch him
hey Aaron thank you for subscribing
Chris thank you for the Super Chat Chris
loved your hype combo with Luke it was
great hey thank you Chris yeah that was
a super fun video
if you guys missed it we talked about it
a little bit on last week's Stream So
Luke Stevens
YouTube fellow YouTuber made a video on
Hogwarts Legacy being skeptical of the
game bringing up some points about why
he was skeptical even though he wanted
to be excited for it
and he got some
I mean half a million views very quickly
on this video
and a lot of people in the Hogwarts
Community reacted or talked about it so
I I talked about it on the live stream
James made some posts on it in his
Discord and I think podcasts now talked
about it maybe some others as well
um but yeah then uh he he invited me he
invited me to be on and so I went went
on to we it was all pre-recorded and we
just had a good conversation I thought
it was a really good conversation
talking about the game
talking about why I'm excited for it
where I still have concerns
where he maybe has concerns and some
that I don't really agree with the
concerns
yeah I thought it was a really good I'm
glad you enjoyed it yeah we've gotten I
was the first couple days I was trying
to read a lot of his comments I haven't
checked it lately but it sounded like a
lot of people enjoyed it as well I mean
that's those deep Dives that's really
kind of what he's known for too I mean
he he goes really really in depth and
picks picks stuff apart I mean you think
we go in depth here
Luke has like three hour plus videos
seven hour plus videos two hour plus
videos where he really breaks down games
so I enjoyed the conversation I know
some people just have a general
different approach to Hype which which
is fine you know some people like to say
I'm gonna set my expectations
just on the floor so I can't be
disappointed that's fine me
dude I'm like put me on the Hogwarts
Express hype train put me on it
I'll be I'll be like the conductor here
James and I
we're conducting the hype train as we go
but then I also try to be realistic too
I try to be realistic
and I know like I see the compare people
want to compare this game to Elden ring
and Skyrim and red dead and what's the
other one there's one more people always
do
Red Dead Elder Rings oh Witcher
and I'm like guys if it can if it even
comes close to those games if it even
comes close
that is incredible
incredible because we're talking
developers who have been doing this like
that type of game for quite literally
decades in some of their cases
and for a studio like Avalanche to just
like burst through the door like that
would be amazing it would be amazing
and it's possible it it's possible
but we'll see we'll see it's just like
it's very
I hesitate to put it to put it on that
pedestal right I mean I don't even think
that's fair to them to be like oh we're
going to compare this to Eldon ring
right I don't think that's fair
and then Jay with a super chat as well
Jay thank you so much gotta head out
can't wait to watch all your videos post
launch pharmacy school takes up all my
time ah so I'll be playing your videos
in the background while I study nice
have a great night Jay thank you for the
Super Chat good luck with pharmacy
school that's no joke
that is no joke
I had a friend who uh went back and went
to pharmacy school a few years ago
but yeah thank you for your support and
hope you enjoy all the videos
so yeah some people are laughingstock
was saying pretty sure Weasley but could
also be Fig's wife
I love the idea of Fig's wife at first
but I just can't figure out how it
how she would get get back
a lot of people think she's not dead
like it says that in the card but what
if she actually ended up not being dead
Fable and Bully had a baby you hope
that's what Hogwarts Legacy is
I never played either of those games
Devin
are you gonna stop being a member now
I'm sorry I've heard so many good things
about
about both of them really but especially
bully like when when it comes to
Hogwarts Legacy people always always
bring a bully
always bring a bully
that's how you found the channel Olivia
nice yeah we've been making
the making videos for quite a while on
it I told uh chat a few weeks ago I said
I want to do our live stream the Monday
night like before the game comes out at
midnight I thought it'd be fun to go
back and watch all of our old videos on
the game
and then Nico looks it up he's like uh
it would take you 16 hours
it might have been more than that
might have been more than that whatever
it was it was just an insane number way
too much for a stream I was like oh oh
that's
that's how many videos that's how many
videos we made on this game never
playing Bully is a sin
we could go back you know what that I
should add that to my uh my let's plays
maybe we could do that sometime after
Hogwarts after Hogwarts comes out and we
beat it and do it do everything there is
to do in it
do you have any criticisms for the game
so far from the showcases
see like where I'm at right now it's
just so hard to say
because we've we've just seen it right
it's a video game it's a game which is
what I've stressed to people the whole
time until you get the controller in
your hands until you play the game
they could show you the most beautiful
trailer they could show you doing the
craziest stunts the most amazing spell
casting
but until you actually play it and
that's part of the reason I know this is
somewhat controversial is I
like as a video gamer
I'm just dad who loves games and the
stories they tell but but if you give me
a choice story or game
I'm choosing the gameplay all day of the
week
all day of the week all day every day
any day of the week yeah that's what I
meant
I'm choosing I'm choosing gameplay over
story like if I want a good story I
could just go I can go read the books
and go watch a movie now
I think Hogwarts Legacy has a chance to
do both I do
and many of the best games my my
favorite game of all time is The Last of
Us we were talking about my
my portrait that I have over here in my
office my favorite game of all time is
The Last of Us and for me
don't want to start any uh
I don't think this is a hot take a lot
of people say last of us is their
favorite game of all time
um
for me The Last of Us was just like this
perfect marriage of gameplay and story
just just
so a story told so beautifully which no
I haven't watched the show yet I'm
trying to wait till all the episodes are
out but all the all these hype tweets
are making it hard to wait they're
making it very hard to wait
I don't want to wait I want to watch it
but I'm going to try to wait try to wait
till all the episodes are out I've heard
it's very good though
but yeah and I mean Hogwarts is in a
position where if they're able to nail
give us a really good Wizarding World
story
and also give us some really good
Wizarding World gameplay then it's
capable of doing something very special
doing something very special
yeah some people do Professor Baxter
every time I say that some people are
like Alba takes story over it and you
know that's fine yeah that's fine
some people do prefer that
and then you have some games like uh
you know like um Wolf Among Us and
Walking Dead where it's pretty much all
story
you're just kind of interacting with it
in a very
not a passive way but just not as um
you're a wizard Harry it's not like
reflexes or anything like that
Josh thank you for subscribing to the
channel
want the game already two weeks two
weeks not much longer to go
uh Josh back to your previous point take
a fair comparison to success would be
Gorilla Games except it would be bigger
since their last game was a cars game
oh like like the history of uh Studios
yeah yeah
watch the show oh we did have that oh my
gosh I don't even know if uh
who was it that was saying I'm so sorry
let's try to do it
Hogwarts Legacy gameplay somebody was
saying
somebody who gave a Super Chat wanted us
to go back
oh this is the wrong one this is
this is the second one I'm pretty sure
they said the first one
all right we'll check that
all right videos Hogwarts Legacy
gameplay showcase this is kind of a
Grand Central Station I love that each
Direction you've broken down this a lot
so they were saying during the
Hufflepuff common room oh my gosh look
at this structure that's the ASMR
all right so
they do the create a character and then
write
here
the combat all right Andrew's got some
gameplay pulled up for us here all right
so whoever's who's hold on I'm gonna
scroll back and see who said that
I think it was Zach right no it wasn't
Zach it was um
oh who was it
who was it Apollo
Apollo 1207 if you're not if you're not
here anymore Apollo I'm sorry I may hope
he catches on the replay so Apollo
donated once speaking of Secrets did you
catch the secret in the Hufflepuff
common room in the Showcase the map of
argosheire and then they said take a
look at the mini map so I think they
mean in this section right here before
we get to that though we had
volte with another Super Chat and then
also Josh was subscribed to the channel
thank you Joshua multi seeing how big
this game is and how much money they are
making I'd expect a lot more stuff from
this company and a lot more frequently
right I mean they've said the blog the
Playstation blog with I think it was
Alan too
pretty sure it was Alan two who said
like we'd love to do more we'd love to
do more
and so far sales are looking pretty good
they're looking pretty good at least if
all these you know charts are to be
believed which
I think they are the game's not I mean
we're still two weeks away from launch
so yeah I mean I'm hoping for DLC and
open for a sequel
like DLC I would feel
more confident about because they can
already see these or at least sales
numbers like oh okay all right
the sequel
I guess it depends on WB is going to
have to wait and see right like
but who knows what like they're pre
they're pre numbers they may maybe they
already have are getting ready to green
light a sequel could you imagine dude
could you imagine
although I on that chat with Luke
speaking of Luke we did have an
interesting conversation about
when open world games do a sequel
they always have to figure out a way
especially if it takes place in the same
area
they always have to have a way to like
freshen up that world so think about
this
if they do a sequel
and we're we're still a student which I
don't think this game is going to take
place over more than a single school
year
but if we start the next game and we're
just back at Hogwarts for a sixth year
how would they
make it feel like a fresh new experience
in the castle
because it it would be the same layout
right it'd be the same layout you'd have
to do like new new puzzles and stuff new
Secrets but then how do you make that
work with the lore and then do you just
repeat some of the secrets and stuff you
already do I don't know I'm fascinated
by that I'm fascinated by that
because I think that's where creatives
come in right that's where the people
who make games that's where they really
get to shine and is come up with ways to
do that all right let's watch this a
little bit and see if we can find any uh
so they were saying to look at the
minimap
US during this section right here so we
see this little icon right here
which most likely marks a quest of some
kind
we got the owl so yeah we already we've
noticed the different owls we've talked
about that before
if you're still here uh
if you're still here
Apollo let me know I'll try to catch the
chat also we have over 20 slottable
spells that you can earn over the course
of the game okay it's hard to change an
already built world
yeah so it's like you think about games
like uh
um to the top left of that Majora's Mask
which is an eyeball they just totally
turn that formula on its head
of essential Templar gaming don't know
if you know already heard there's a way
every time you get a Super Chat
automatically puts it into an Excel
sheet and you don't have to scroll back
and forth
so I have uh Templar what I have
represents where you might slide I have
an activity feed that is through stream
elements
which shows me everyone that pops in so
I can just like
I can just scroll through that instead
of having to scroll through chat
all right so what a one everybody look
for Apollo's comment
s
see if Apollo
said anything
Maria's hope he can turn off only the
mini map
well they've definitely said you can
customize
certain parts of the HUD and some
they've even clarified specifics
it's in that big thread that wizard PhD
has done on Twitter
I'm pretty sure pretty sure it's in
there where you are currently thank you
our man thank you for subscribing
all right you guys notice anything here
yet that we missed
also options to remove the mini map and
turn on or off different elements of our
HUD immerse yourself yeah yeah and we'll
go more into the Spells as we get into
combat but that's kind of that's that's
what you're seeing there and this is our
HUD also Andrew's giving us over here
I just saw your comment Hannah
that is so funny
Hannah said my husband and I were just
talking about you he asked what's your
name is I said retro and he said no his
real name
Rose you have no idea I don't say it a
lot it's not it's not a secret it's
Jonathan Jonathan is my real name
I was talking to people about that the
other day it was like yeah I just never
it's just I'm retro wrecking to her just
a dad who loves games on the stories
they tell most people call me Retro
Music
School most people that I meet through
okay wait maybe they were talking about
the minimap here so you got the flu
Flame
yeah retro is fine
people rarely ever call me entirely
people that meet me through the Stream
or through the stuff I do online it's
almost always retro
I think he's talking about Majestic dad
said do you think what he's talking
about is right after that there you go
feathers did you know or did you just
after I said it
I'm sure oh my goodness Luna wants back
out guys
Dancing
Yeah she she likes to come and go she's
gonna get mad that I left it open
sharp your name's Jonathan too
there's somebody else who stops by here
a lot whose name is Jonathan does it
does but I I know you don't want to
leave but we're going to be leaving
Johnny the hustle puffer Russell retro
if you look at the spot where everyone
says that it is smoke
and not water
if you look there are waterfalls in the
background and just before the scene
changes our character is covered in
covered in a shield
oh yeah the secret room on the map when
you enter the lounge area
so I need to back up probably right I
think it's right after we see peeves
wait do we see peas in this section
good night Jake have a good one
they are at the bookcase the bookcase
the bookcase the bookcase oh okay people
are saying bookcase
all right so let's go back a little bit
oh that's probably too far back
so I mean beautiful design I I we could
spend like oh yeah yeah where people
think it's a secret room and I'm sure
Boston and James could be like just
geeking out over here this all the
details come from JK Rowling's writings
for this common room the round doors the
hanging Vines even the dancing Badgers
on the fireplace
oh yeah yeah going up the stairs is when
you see peeves
next to the fireplace
okay I'm gonna wait for a second because
there's a little bit of a lag
a little bit of a lag so I want to make
sure that I'm right I'm in the right
spot
Majestic dad with the Super Chat hey
thank you Majestic dad check the map
spot
behind the bookshelf
okay
uh so Johnny you're talking about
something different
this is a comment we had earlier about
someone asking if we found the secret in
the Hufflepuff common room
all right so David said just keep
playing okay we're gonna keep playing it
yeah
[Music]
which is which is like elements for each
of the houses right oh yeah right here
right here right here
that might be what they were taught what
Apollo was talking about call
yeah
yeah I do remember people pointing this
out I can't remember if I talked about
it in any of our videos
yeah I mean hopefully the Castle's just
full of stuff like this right
so there's probably going to be a way
for you to interact with that maybe
just a little bit further
that's not it
um
oh you're a good Zach I actually didn't
even see I didn't even see the post but
yeah don't don't feel bad or anything
mods are just uh
they're just making sure to hide any
anything that's been not officially
released by Avalanche so some people
just want to totally avoid spoilers so
yeah if that's when you're talking about
though
clearly it looks like there is there's
something behind there yeah for sure
and then we had let's see Supernova
Skies with a five dollar Super Chat wait
Retro's name is retro
it's all my birth certificate guys Retro
Retro
no no
I wonder if there's actually anybody
named retro though that'd be cool what a
what a cool name that would be hopefully
it should feel very familiar yeah yeah
it does it does have a good night
gravity thank you for being here
that was it okay perfect perfect
it could be it could be a secret
like Moon Lily looking back
kind of hearing Hogwarts is now but now
because the door up up around here they
take a left right here that's the one
that's the one that is um
leads right into the kitchens we know
for sure all right so thank you for that
one other thing
that I want to check
before we go tonight before we go before
we go is the recent posts
so we had
this post right here so we didn't get to
talk about this one so we had the grab
horn so it looks like they're doing
creatures now for the character cards
and they do have they do have a little
sound effects with them too so if you
didn't turn on your sound make sure you
turn on your sound if you see them post
any additional ones
so we got the grapporn here a large
mountain dwelling beasts that have a
tough hide and two sharp horns and are
known for their aggressive nature
they're tentacle-like
appendages are used for capturing food
and tending to their young so we have
that one
and then we had the Mandrake seedly
which
I love that they included we can use
these in battle oh does this one not
have any sound
I guess they want to despair us
they probably want to despair us you
know have a good one Dr sherbet thank
you for being here
Mandrake seedling a magical plant that
shrieks when Unearthed mandrakes can be
used to stun and harm enemies in a
radius
so this is so crazy I mean they like
nailed the I love the visual look of
them
so good
and then last but not least
we have the moon calf which was today's
oh and this one does have sound so I I
bet they just didn't do a moon calf
sound because they or or a uh
they just didn't do the oh my gosh
it's getting late Mandrake they didn't
do the Mandrake sound because they
didn't want to hurt our ears
oh look at the little Moon calf moocab
is a small calf-like Beast with enormous
eyes and a shy personality that can be
observed dancing when the light of the
full moon hits the ground
man you know people are just gonna have
a
a vivarium full of moon calves
the varium full of these Moon calves
all right and let's see we had another
uh
another subscription come in Captain
thank you for subscribing and Elwyn with
a super chat give me all the beasts
happy dance
thank you for the Super Chat Elwyn I
know it's gonna be so fun with beasts
it's gonna be so fun with the Beast
all right I want to
you guys have we hit well over 200 likes
I think we're over 300 likes thank you
guys so much for your support if you're
new here whenever we hit 100 likes on
the stream we do a random
Harry Potter quote trivia
so you guys tell me the the character
and you tell me the book you get one
point if you get the character you get
one point for the book
and so last week's was too easy
last week was way too easy we got to go
difficult this week
we've got to go difficult
all right so I've got the book I've got
the book I want
now I need to find the quote now I need
to find the quote
GC night walker dude thank you for the
Super Chat found you from the Luke
Stevens stream completely unknown to me
you also decided to go through every
pre-existing HV game did you know there
are like 25 considering how early PS1
and PC handheld versions had completely
different gameplay sections yes dude
GC first of all thank you for the Super
Chat my friend I'm glad you uh enjoyed
the chat with Luke that was a good time
and so I have been going through I don't
think I'm gonna get to all of them
before Legacy but yeah I'm up to order
of the Phoenix but I I skipped a couple
too
I have a video one of the most viewed
videos on my channel GC
not not to plug a video not to plug a
video but it's exactly what you're
talking about
I made a video called the complete
history of Harry Potter video games it's
the most
most work and writing I've ever done for
video
and I know if you're a fan of Luke's
it'll probably seem small coming from
his videos because he he has some videos
that are pretty up there but for me it
was one of the longest videos I've ever
done
um I think it's almost 40 minutes and it
is just a complete
honestly I could it could have been way
longer because I've been seeing a lot of
these channels on YouTube and I'd seen a
lot of these videos that were like
history of Harry Potter games and it's
literally just like a few clips and it
shows you
a couple of sections of video and that's
it and I was like no man we need some
commentary we need some context we need
a little bit of a you know a story to
tell through this
so I I did it I did it and I tried to
hit every single game and I knew about
some of the stuff
but I did not know welcome I did not
know all of like exactly like what
you're talking about how for the first
three it was like the PC was made by no
wonder and then the console versions
were completely different developer
which is so bizarre like if you think
about the way games are made today so
bizarre
then from four on that's when they kind
of merged and they were a lot more
similar but yeah yeah dude and thank you
for the membership as well look at that
GC with the membership
welcome to house rack and tour my friend
by the power of Thor's hammer
enjoy your emotes enjoy the uh
special Discord roll and also we do a I
think you get like a yeah merch discount
as well
but thank you so much GC glad you found
the stream and if you if you guys
haven't seen that video yet it's like
it's still one of my most viewed videos
ever on the channel
um but yeah I might have to update it
now like after Hogwarts comes out we
might have to update it right
we might have to update it all right so
this week for our random bit of trivia
oh this they're too easy too easy the
quotes I'm seeing right now
way too easy I got to come up with with
someone
got to come up with something more
difficult last week's was really easy
you guys got it like right away
okay let me see this one
this one might be difficult
hmm
you love the hoodie Ravel claw
no dude I'm a big fan too it's uh so
this is official Hogwarts Legacy merch
if you guys didn't know Chandler
confirmed on Twitter they are officially
licensed so
there's a link an Amazon affiliate Link
in the description if you guys are
interested you could use my link and it
uh it's no extra charge to you it helps
out the stream a little bit
hope the happy Hogwarts theme is in
Hogwarts Legacy I don't think
I don't think so but from what we've
heard like they've absolutely nailed the
music
they've absolutely nailed it all right
we'll try this one
it might be easy again but I think it I
don't know we'll see we'll see we'll see
all right here it is guys first name the
character and then name the book
and I'm not going to give you any of
like the in-between I'm just gonna give
you the the full line from the character
I'm not going to give you any of like
the so-and-so said with a
you know
harsh tone in their voice I'm not going
to say anything like that
you've got to listen to me you'll regret
it if you don't you don't understand
there we go
you've got to listen to me you'll regret
it if you don't
you don't understand
first tell me the character
and then tell me the book
you've got to listen to me you'll regret
it if you don't you don't understand
don't don't Google it
come on
have a little fun
all right let's see let's see
of course Britney's the first one
Brittany of course
Britney Sirius book three uh Anna Luna's
dad and Deathly Hallows series book
three serious POA Cedric book four snake
book five Harry book five Mr Weasley
book three series book Three Harry book
one Hermione
give it a give it a little bit longer
see what other ones trickle in here slug
horn hapla Prince grip hook book six
Arthur book three Sorcerer's Stone when
Harry confronts McGonagall serious POA
Neville book four a character one of the
books
come on inside chapter cat rat and dog
Brittany you can't go first anymore you
can't go first anymore Brittany Arthur
book three Moon Lily serious book three
xenophilius Deathly Hallows I could see
why I could see why some people would
say xenophilius yeah but Brittany nailed
it I think Britney has gotten it every
week
I'm pretty sure Britney has gotten it
every week yeah it's Sirius in book
three
it is when obviously he's trying to
explain to Harry everything that's going
on because Harry still thinks that he
was the one
you sold them to Voldemort that's all I
need to know that was Harry you've got
to listen to me black said and there was
a note of urgency in his voice now
you'll regret it if you don't you don't
understand I understand a lot better
than you think said Harry and his voice
shook more than ever you never heard her
did you my mum trying to stop Voldemort
killing me and you did that you did it
you're a wizard Harry oh just reading
that little bit man takes me back to
that tension reading that scene for the
first time as a
I don't know
16 year old kid 15 year old however old
I was
so so
insane that moment
so insane
all right so that was for hitting 100
likes now for hitting 200 likes you guys
get a random Harry Potter impression
What's it gonna be
What's it gonna be we've done Bellatrix
we've done Draco we've done Snape we've
done Ollivander we've done Dobby
I think those are the ones that we've
done
which I'm not opposed to to redoing I
just kind of like to keep it uh kind of
like to keep it fresh
oh dude we I wish
I wish I had
if any of you take the time at some
point
if any of you are bored one day
you could go back through all it's like
at the very end of most of the stream
although sometimes I think we did it
earlier I'd love for us to be able to
put up a comparison put up all the
Impressions and then like let you guys
vote on the best one
I still think my uh my Umbridge my uh I
think my Ollivander is the best which is
the very first one that I've ever done
all right let's see what's popping up
the most here
oh Elwyn Umbridge would be fun
mad I mood Mad Eye Moody would be good
creature would be good
we got another for Umbridge dark lord
Luna Umbridge
see sometimes chat you just get the
perfect
sometimes people give me the perfect
line
and I have to do it
Chris's quote of where have you been
wait hold on I'm thinking of a different
you being
I'm thinking of somebody else who's I'm
thinking of moon Mrs Weasley says that
Chris
oh we're seeing a lot of them Bridge
though
oh but then a lot of lucious Malfoy's
jumping in there McGonagall
that little door Harry we definitely
need to do that one at some point
Templar Hagrid quote Lockhart
different quotes in the Davi impression
wrong quote from first movie when he's
telling Harry
you're the one that has to
stick I know it you're a wizard that
doesn't count that doesn't count I'll
give you guys I'll do a legit one
I really want I think I'm gonna do
Umbridge I think I'm gonna do Umbridge
I'm gonna do Umbridge
obviously I'm gonna do I will have order
but I want another thing too
Dolores Umbridge movie quote
tindolores Umbridge quotes that should
have been in the movies oh these weren't
never I feel like I need it to be in the
movies because I need to be able to hear
it
well what am I doing you guys are gonna
give me a line anyway I already know you
are
foreign
bonus because I want to do Knicks not me
not Hermione you
not me Harry not Hermione
you
you're the one that has to go on I know
it
fine if I find you guys get bonus bonus
tonight bonus
I want to do I will have order but what
else does Umbridge say like what's
another good one
Pete my Snape one wasn't that good I'll
be honest Alan rickman's tough tough one
to uh
to do I was a little too fast
with my with my Snape
that's uh that's Snape Ryan
Dobby's quote Bellatrix
wait
sorry I must not tell lies Harry said it
movie five
David you're really good I need to be a
voice actor I have done a little bit of
a
voice acting I have for like small uh
like on um
a little small I guess they're called
like flash games or something like that
a few years ago I did a little bit of
that
you mustn't tell lies oh
yeah the him him
I admit Retro's got skills
you just need to clear your throat okay
all right hold on I'll do I'll do the
clear of the throat and I'll do I will
have order
oh it's it's called tea again
I feel like I need to start with I will
have order because that's like her
see oh
anytime I do the the ladies like it's
hard to get that high
foreign
I will have older
and then and then we gotta get the
ah It's gotta be louder
oh you're here in my chair
you're here in my chair there
[Music]
that's the best I could do for that one
and then hold on what was the one that
uh
Zach gave me a good line too
she's like she's like all mad in that
one right detention
oh there's another one what is
there's something else she says with
Harry
I must know
I do remember the detention detention Mr
oh wait what's what's the line
what's the line where she says um
what is the line
where she tells them that they don't
need to like do real magic
oh Chrissy yes
oh okay yeah that's a good one that's a
good one
I'm trying to remember how Softly She
says it because she says that one really
soft right
that one's more that one's a little bit
softer
I will have Alta
deep down you know that you deserve to
be punished don't you Mr Porter
how's that that was pretty close right
that's pretty close
so past your examinations which is that
school's all about
the chat's always delayed so there's
that awkward part where I'm like oh dude
I totally bombed that one was totally
terrible they don't even they're not
even
they're not even giving me like a seven
out of ten they're just like they're not
responding it's very very nerve-wracking
time let me tell you it's only like five
seconds but it's it's nerve-wracking
trust me
oh my gosh
all right you guys have got more than
you bargained for tonight you got more
of the market for tonight that was fun
though that was fun GC Walker with
another Super Chat don't judge vids on
how much effort went in doesn't matter
it's right
to YouTube learn that the hard way as a
small Creator my most watched is is
goblet it was torture or oh do you
replay them on your channel as well GC
that's very cool very cool
very cool but you're right like I have a
video that blew up on it was made on a
tweet that was one word
it was it was made on a tweet that was
one word one word here I'll show you
guys you guys the regulars you already
know
you already know
but
so everybody wanted to know for the
longest time if you could jump in
Hogwarts Legacy you know what's crazy
about this guys I almost didn't make
this video I almost didn't
so they the community came out or
Chandler would no wait they post that on
the actual Hogwarts account didn't they
jump it was one word
I was like I guess
I didn't want to just make the video
about a single tweet though six minutes
right and that's where some of the
commenters I'm like you didn't even
watch the video clearly
457 000 views video I almost didn't even
make
but instead of just being like hey you
can show me Hogwarts Legacy I took I
looked at Eldon ring and I looked at god
of war and how
they both kind of reversed what had
traditionally been done in those
franchises and how you know Souls
traditionally
they kind of had a jump but it wasn't a
true jump you know
and then how they added one with elder
ring and then how God of War went the
other way and I looked at those two and
I talked about how the fact that jump is
confirmed in Hogwarts Legacy is actually
a pretty big deal and how it could
relate certain gameplay elements
six minute video never thought it would
do that never thought I would do that
yeah I'm glad you guys enjoyed the
Impressions though David was here with
the Super Chat as well 150 points to
Gryffindor 10 out of 10 hey thank you
David
thank you very much David
thank you nutmeg yeah I'm glad you guys
enjoyed it there are a lot of people
like I can't believe I just watched uh
I can't believe this video
it's so funny the videos that often blow
up I mean you're gonna have more
haters on them anyway but
all right guys it is almost 11 p.m my
time
it's almost 11 p.m we have been going
for
how long you been going for
I've been going for over three out we
just crossed the three hours
oh good good good call Professor Baxter
yeah yeah before we go
I really was curious about that I wanted
to know
so with the poll question we asked guys
and we had 540 votes almost at 400 likes
can we hit 400 likes before we go helps
more people find the stream even after
it finishes posting we're at 375 guys if
25 of you are in here and you haven't
hit that Thumbs Up Button consider
hitting it before you go
really helps the video out helps more
people find it even after the fact so we
asked would you want to see Hogwarts
like demo before launch 61 said yes
39 said no
I'm Gladden in the poll interesting I
thought it would be
all right I'm not feeling this I'm not
feeling this music
villain that one at all
Dustin what in the world are you kidding
me
Dustin with a 50 dollar Super Chat
Dustin has been showing ridiculous
amounts of support quite literally this
entire stream
a 50 Super Chat
Dustin my man thank you so much dude
this is going to be my last stream other
than James's tomorrow until mid-February
so glad to be a part of this stream and
Community thank you retro for being such
a great content creator and streamer
wanted tonight to be a big Night hits
why I'm on PC Dustin dude
thank you so much man
thank you so much
so what now I'm curious though is it
like you know personal situation you
don't want to talk about or is it like
Hogwarts like I say you're going you
want to go dark for the next
two and a half weeks
through through launch of the game until
you finish it
I'm curious
I hope everything's okay dude I hope
it's hope it's something like that
but Dustin thank you so much man
James tomorrow yeah yeah James will be
going live for Wizarding Wednesday I'm
assuming at the usual time
okay good good good Dustin I was you
worry me for a little second I was like
I hope it's nothing serious okay going
dark gotcha gotcha gotcha
I gotcha
oh man it's been it's been incredibly
incredibly fun ride having you here I
hope you'll hope you'll be back after
launch
hope you'll be back after launch but
yeah it's like we're kind of hitting
that time you know if you don't want to
know anything
don't know anything
then yeah
sorry Zach you gotta wait till next week
gotta wait till next week
I can't just like chat see what happens
is I'm always like a little reluctant
I'm a little shy to dive into the pool
then chat gets me in there and then they
just like you start throwing all these
lines and I'm like okay come on now
you just got me so into it we did like
five in one day we'll save that even
though technically that is not a uh
it's not a movie quote that's a gamey
quote
that's a gaming quote
but Dustin dude thank you very much yet
again
and yeah we'll see you we'll see in a
few weeks whenever you whenever you beat
the game
Austin I'll try to be here next Tuesday
also I'll be using fulfindo on every
product I can find in the game like it's
Sorcerer's Stone
gotcha
oh by the by the way by the way Dustin
by the way before you go before you go
we may possibly be doing an another
stream tomorrow
not going to be at the same time as
James don't worry don't worry
keep an eye out
because
there might be a video that I want to
talk about
talk about and I feel like a live stream
is a good place to do it
so there you go
so if you want to make if you want to
make exception for you don't have to do
any more Super chats Dustin but
but you work till 4 30
should be it should be around our usual
time
should be around our usual our usual
but yeah guys thank you all very much
for the support
um enjoy the ride man enjoy the ride as
I've said always
throughout this whole hype and lead up
to the game enjoy the ride we only have
two weeks left
and
there's gonna be some fun days man
there's gonna be some really fun days
for the community
and it's just going to be it's gonna be
a good time so remember to stop
and enjoy the moment
because once you know once it's here man
once it's here things change they will
they'll change and it'll be great you
know it'll be fun we'll have the game in
our hands
but yeah enjoy it enjoy the journey guys
thank you all very much for being here
your support means the world to me we
hit 400 likes
you guys are the best
and you could guys anybody watching us a
replay Squad you can like it again and
it's gonna be like YouTube's gonna be
saying hey what in the world is this we
need there's a live stream that
it's a VOD but people are still liking
it they're going crazy let's show this
to more people
let's get more people here in-house
racket tour
all right guys
man I'm starting to get like I'm
starting to feel this like emotion a
little bit you know
of only we only have one Tuesday stream
left
only one of our of our weekly Tuesday
streams that we've been doing for quite
some time now
one of them left before launch we're
gonna keep doing them don't worry
but like the before you know the before
times
only one
and there will be then we'll be
streaming like
the Monday before the game comes out
but yeah guys keep an eye keep an eye on
tomorrow
um on my Twitter
on my uh if you're in the Discord I'll
be sure to post there as well
but yeah I got I got a video hitting in
the morning that you guys are gonna be
really excited for you're gonna enjoy
seeing it
unless plans change that's the plan
right now
and let me know what you think when you
guys see this video as you always do
um watch it
comment on the video Let me let me know
what you think in the comments
thumbs up if you like it and if you
don't thumbs down it's okay
but just uh yeah yeah make sure you're
there
and enjoy guys thank you all so much for
watching
I'll talk to you again soon
[Music]